in their old machines. You haunt the space between breath on machines. Hey guys, it's Joel, and welcome back to psychotherapy on the couch, a psychohistory of American psychology. What psychology can see, what it can't see, and why it has trouble telling the difference. Welcome to episode six. Do not fold, spindle, or mutilate.
在旧机器中。你徘徊在机器的呼吸之间。嘿，大家好，我是乔尔，欢迎回到《沙发上的心理治疗》，一部美国心理学的心理史。心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分两者。欢迎来到第六集。请勿折叠、穿孔或损毁。
In the summer of 1979, Jimmy Carter went to Camp David for 10 days, and he canceled a, scheduled energy speech. He called in pollsters and pastors and economists and ordinary citizens, and he listened to them, included a lot of those conversations in the speech he would give. And what he came back with was one of the weirder speeches that a sitting American president has ever attempted. You know, officially it was about the energy crisis, but functionally it was about the soul. And Carter said that the country was in a crisis of confidence. He said it was a
1979年夏天，吉米·卡特在戴维营待了10天，并取消了一场预定的能源演讲。他召集了民意测验专家、牧师、经济学家和普通公民，倾听他们的意见，并将其中许多对话内容纳入了他即将发表的演讲中。他带回来的演讲是美国在任总统尝试过的最奇怪的演讲之一。你知道，从官方层面看，它是关于能源危机的，但从功能层面看，它是关于灵魂的。卡特说，这个国家正处于信心危机之中。他说这是一种
crisis that you could see in the growing doubt about the meaning of our own lives and in the loss of unity and purpose for our nation. And he said, too many of us now tend to worship self-indulgence and consumption. Human identity is no longer defined by what one does, but what one owns. And he said that piling up material goods cannot fulfill the emptiness of life, which when we have no confidence or purpose. And this was a sitting president essentially doing depth psychology. the country. He was naming in 79 exactly the wound that we traced in the last episode, or the most recent iteration of it, the collapse of the mythology, the void left behind, and the way that Americans were trying to fill that void with consumption that could not
你可以在对我们自身生活意义的日益怀疑，以及我们国家失去团结和目标中看到的危机。他还说，我们现在太多人倾向于崇拜自我放纵和消费。人类的身份不再由一个人做了什么来定义，而是由他拥有什么来定义。他说，堆积物质财富无法填补生活的空虚，而这正是我们缺乏信心或目标的时候。这实际上是一位在任总统在进行深度心理学分析。他在79年准确地指出了我们在上一集追踪到的创伤，或者说是它最近的一次迭代，即神话的崩溃，留下的虚无，以及美国人试图用无法填补的消费来填补这种虚无的方式。
possibly ever fill it. You know, hungry ghosts in the Buddhist sense is what he was accusing the country of becoming. And he was trying to do for the country what a good therapist does for a patient, and he was trying to put words to what the patient could feel but couldn't say. The press called it the malaise speech, even though Carter never used the word malaise in the speech, and it really killed his presidency. Asking America to have a different relationship to the hero myth or to consumption is one that you can't do and has never been done since. And because Americans did not want a therapist, they wanted a father who could tell them everything was going to be fine, and especially that everything was going to be fine if they just kept doing what they'd done before. And so 18 months later, Ronald Reagan stood on stage and gave the opposite speech.
这根本无法填补。你知道，他指责这个国家正在变成佛教意义上的“饿鬼”。他试图为国家做一位好治疗师为病人所做的事，他试图用语言表达出病人能感觉到却说不出来的东西。媒体称之为“萎靡演讲”，尽管卡特在演讲中从未用过“萎靡”这个词，但这确实扼杀了他的总统生涯。要求美国人与英雄神话或消费建立不同的关系，这是你做不到的，而且自那以后也从未有人做到过。因为美国人不需要治疗师，他们想要一位能告诉他们一切都会好起来的父亲，尤其是如果他们继续做以前做过的事，一切都会好起来。于是18个月后，罗纳德·里根站在台上发表了截然相反的演讲。
mourning in America. America is a shining city on a hill. The government is not the solution to our problem. The government is the problem. Where Carter's speech had been an attempt at integration, you know, it said there's something that is wrong, the wrongness isn't us, and we have to look at it together. Healing is possible if we do that and a community and meaning with a solution. Reagan's speech was an act of repression. It said, there's nothing wrong with us. The wrongness is in them, bureaucrats, Russians, the welfare queens, the regulators, and if we just get rid of them, we will be fine. They're the reason that you feel this way. And one speech named the wound and the other named a scapegoat, but the scapegoat was infinitely more appealing, and the country chose to scapegoat and a 44 state landslide.
美国在哀悼。美国是山巅之城。政府不是我们问题的解决方案。政府就是问题所在。卡特的演讲是一种整合的尝试，你知道，它说有些事情出了问题，错误不在我们，我们必须一起面对。如果我们这样做，治愈是有可能的，社区和意义是解决方案。里根的演讲是一种压抑的行为。它说，我们没有错。错误在于他们，官僚、俄国人、福利女王、监管者，如果我们摆脱了他们，我们就会好起来。他们是你感觉如此的原因。一场演讲指出了创伤，另一场演讲指出了替罪羊，但替罪羊的吸引力无限大，国家选择了替罪羊，并在44个州大获全胜。
And I want to spend a minute on why that happened, because it wasn't a political event, or I'm not talking about this as a political argument. It was a generational absorption. To understand how psychology got its marching orders in 1980, which were building towards, you have to understand what happened to the people who decided a decade earlier that they would no longer be these potential loud voices against what Reagan was selling, or a voice selling something else, so that there could have been a conversation. In 64, there were students at Berkeley that held up signs at a free speech protest that said, I am a UC student. Please do not fold, bend, spindle, or mutilate me. They also had that on T-shirts. And the punch card,
我想花点时间谈谈为什么会发生这种情况，因为它不是一个政治事件，或者我不是把它当作一个政治论点来谈。这是一种代际吸收。要理解心理学在1980年是如何接到指令的——我们正朝着这个方向发展——你必须理解那些在十年前决定不再成为里根所兜售的东西的潜在响亮声音，或者兜售其他东西的声音的人身上发生了什么，这样本可以有一场对话。在64年，伯克利的抗议学生在言论自由抗议中举着牌子，上面写着：“我是加州大学的学生。请勿折叠、弯曲、穿孔或损毁我。”他们还在T恤上印了这些字。而打孔卡，
the IBM punch card, which you used to program the earliest computers. You couldn't really input code, so you had to basically punch it into a card, like a grid, and that was the language that it spoke. If you got one dot wrong, the whole program didn't work, he had to start over. So if you had 300 of these in a stack, they were incredibly valuable. And if it was something that was, you know, a banking record or your student card that you were registering for classes or, you know, entering your social security number, you had to make sure it was right. And if it was bent or mutilated or put on a spindle, which, you know, people did,
IBM打孔卡，你过去用来编程最早的计算机。你无法真正输入代码，所以你必须基本上把它打进一张卡片里，就像一个网格，那就是它所说的语言。如果你错了一个点，整个程序就无法运行，你必须从头开始。所以如果你有一叠300张这样的卡片，它们就非常有价值。如果它是某种，你知道，银行记录，或者你注册课程的学生证，或者，你知道，输入你的社会安全号码，你必须确保它是正确的。如果它被弯曲、损毁或放在主轴上，你知道，人们确实这样做过，
cards in those times, then it wouldn't work. And it had to be a stiff, stocky card that the machine could scan quickly. And the IBM card had those instructions printed on the top margin. And the instructions warned the machine operator needed you to not damage this card because the card was data and the data was the person. Because the data was the person at Berkeley in 64. The mass influx of students had meant that there was a new kind of bureaucracy that needed to happen. There were giant movements that were too big to manage with traditional bureaucracy, with traditional structures. We now needed to atomize them into data. And this was how kids registered for classes. It was how they got their grades. It was how they communicated with the system that no longer had a person
那个时代的卡片，那么它就无法工作。它必须是一张坚硬、厚实的卡片，机器才能快速扫描。IBM卡片的上边缘印有这些说明。说明警告机器操作员需要你不要损坏这张卡片，因为卡片就是数据，而数据就是人。因为在64年的伯克利，数据就是人。学生的大量涌入意味着需要一种新的官僚机构。有巨大的运动，大到无法用传统官僚机构、传统结构来管理。我们现在需要把它们原子化为数据。这就是孩子们注册课程的方式。这就是他们获得成绩的方式。这就是他们与不再有人的系统沟通的方式，
that they could speak to. And it pissed them off. You know, the Berkeley kids held up these signs making, you know, themselves into the card, being like, I'm the one that you shouldn't utilize. Don't make me respect this card. It's not better than me. And so there were rallies and there where students strikes because the students refused to be treated like data or to treat computers and bureaucracy is more important than themselves. You know, the same thing that a lot of Carter voters or black, uh, not Carter voters were angry about when Reagan said, hey, bureaucracy is the bad guy. And they said, hell yeah. This is a world of increasing bureaucracy. These students sit on the steps as, you know, lefties. And they said, you will not mutilate us. You will not
他们可以与之交谈。这让他们很生气。你知道，伯克利的孩子们举着这些牌子，把自己变成卡片，好像在说，我是你不应该利用的那个人。别让我尊重这张卡片。它并不比我好。所以有集会，有学生罢工，因为学生拒绝被当作数据对待，或者拒绝把计算机和官僚机构看得比他们自己更重要。你知道，里根说“嘿，官僚机构是坏人”时，许多卡特选民或黑人，呃，非卡特选民感到愤怒的也是同一件事。他们说，该死，是的。这是一个官僚机构日益增长的世界。这些学生坐在台阶上，你知道，作为左派。他们说，你们不会损毁我们。你们不会
turn us into data. And we are, uh, demanding. humans to interact with. Human system, not machine systems. But we're a bunch of raw materials that don't mean to have any process upon us. Don't mean to be made into any product. Don't mean to end up being bought by some clients of the university. Be they the government, be they industry, be they organized labor, be they anyone for human beings. Separation of the machine becomes so odious. Makes you so sick at heart that you can't take part. You can't even pass.
把我们变成数据。我们是，呃，要求与之互动的人类。人类系统，而不是机器系统。但我们是一堆原材料，不打算让任何程序作用于我们。不打算被制成任何产品。不打算最终被大学的某些客户购买。无论是政府，还是工业界，还是有组织的劳工，还是任何为了人类的人。与机器的分离变得如此令人厌恶。让你心生厌恶，以至于你无法参与。你甚至无法通过。
massively take part. And you've got to put your bodies upon the gears and upon the wheels, upon the levers, upon all the apparatus, and you've got to make it stop. And you've got to indicate to the people who run it, to the people who own it, that unless you're free, the machine will be prevented from working at all. So as Savio is saying there, you know, this was a demand. It was a moral demand to put your body on the gears of the apparatus, on the levers, on the wheels, and stop the machine if the machine will not stop being odious to you. And it's one of the most extraordinary things any American student has said into a microphone, you know, and it's one of the least
大规模参与。你必须把你的身体放在齿轮上，放在轮子上，放在杠杆上，放在所有的装置上，你必须让它停止。你必须向那些运行它的人，向那些拥有它的人表明，除非你自由，否则机器将根本无法工作。所以正如萨维奥在那里所说的，你知道，这是一个要求。这是一个道德要求，把你的身体放在装置的齿轮上，放在杠杆上，放在轮子上，如果机器不停止对你的厌恶，就停止机器。这是任何美国学生对着麦克风说出的最非凡的事情之一，你知道，它是最少
quoted, you know, at least in the mainstream, you know, cybernatics and some other, you know, historians use it. But it is a spiritual ancestor, you know, that moment of many things that happened to psychotherapy and other American systems after that date. It was about the mainframe being an enemy, the machine as enemy, and the whole apparatus of bureaucratic rationality that had gotten into the country after Vietnam because of Vietnam, the amount of processing and the amount of scale that these systems had to have. Because it was these students noticing that after Vietnam scaled the military to become a system that required machine logic, that that machine logic was being brought home,
被引用的，你知道，至少在主流中，你知道，控制论和其他一些，你知道，历史学家使用它。但它是一个精神祖先，你知道，在那之后发生在心理治疗和其他美国系统身上的许多事情的那个时刻。它是关于大型机作为敌人，机器作为敌人，以及在越南之后，因为越南，这些系统必须具备的处理量和规模，而进入国家的整个官僚理性装置。因为正是这些学生注意到，在越南将军事规模化为需要机器逻辑的系统之后，那种机器逻辑被带回了国内，
and the entire country was now being treated in the same way that this military apparatus that had been created to run Vietnam and the DoD forever onward would be turned to end word and we would run the country that way. We would not treat everyone like a soldier, but we would start to treat everybody like a product and like a cog in the machine the same way that the military had. You know, and the summer of love collapsed in 67 with, you know, there was the death of the hippie parade in Height Ashbury that was this sort of a parody of, you know, the hippies dying off. Heroin was coming in after Vietnam. A lot of these people were getting hooked on harder drugs. And, you know, and it was now, you know, the needle instead of psychedelics.
整个国家现在正以同样的方式被对待，这种为运行越南和国防部而创造的军事装置将永远转向国内，我们将以那种方式运行国家。我们不会把每个人都当作士兵，但我们会开始把每个人都当作产品和机器中的齿轮，就像军队所做的那样。你知道，爱之夏在67年崩溃了，你知道，海特-阿什伯里发生了嬉皮士游行死亡事件，这是一种，你知道，嬉皮士消亡的模仿。海洛因在越南之后进来了。这些人中的许多人开始沉迷于更硬的毒品。而且，你知道，现在是，你知道，针头而不是迷幻药。
and, you know, dirtweed. And, you know, Manson, Charles Manson happened in 69. Altamont happened three months later. The weather underground, they went militant. And then that movement went nowhere and largely didn't have a symbol to rebel against after Vietnam. So they turned themselves in and they got acquitted because the government had been collecting information on them illegally, basically, with Quintel Pro. And, you know, Nixon is reelected in a landslide in 72. The oil embargo hit in 73.
还有，你知道，劣质大麻。而且，你知道，曼森，查尔斯·曼森发生在69年。阿尔塔蒙特音乐节三个月后发生。地下气象员，他们变得激进。然后那场运动无处可去，在越南之后基本上没有了反抗的象征。所以他们自首了，他们被判无罪，因为政府基本上一直在用反情报计划非法收集他们的信息。而且，你知道，尼克松在72年以压倒性优势连任。石油禁运在73年爆发。
stagflation, 18% interest rates. You know, your commune did not have health insurance for your kid anymore. It wasn't fun. And you had a kid now because it had been a decade and you were tired. So nobody put their body on the gears. The bodies went into the gears, one after another, and the gears kept turning. And after a few years, nobody could even remember what the gears were supposed to grind to a halt for. And nobody could feel them.
滞胀，18%的利率。你知道，你的公社不再为你的孩子提供健康保险了。这并不好玩。而且你现在有了孩子，因为已经过去十年了，你累了。所以没有人把身体放在齿轮上。身体一个接一个地进入了齿轮，齿轮继续转动。几年后，甚至没有人记得齿轮本应为了什么而停止转动。没有人能感觉到它们。
There was a mass dissociation. And so when the hippies dispersed, you know what happened to the hippies it's it's actually documented demographically pretty well you know the largest group of them they didn't just go one place but the biggest group became yuppies they were these young urban professionals like the kind of thing they got made fun of in like you know mid-80s movies and they cut their hair and they got mortgages and they entered the formal labor force and they kept the social liberalism but they lost the economic radicalism and you know jerry rubin you know the yippie who'd been arrested in chicago you know
发生了一场大规模的解离。所以当嬉皮士散去时，你知道嬉皮士发生了什么，这在人口统计学上记录得相当好，你知道，他们中最大的一群人，他们并没有只去一个地方，但最大的一群人变成了雅皮士，他们是这些年轻的城市专业人士，就像80年代中期电影里嘲笑的那种人，他们剪了头发，买了抵押贷款，进入了正式劳动力市场，他们保留了社会自由主义，但失去了经济激进主义，而且，你知道，杰里·鲁宾，你知道，在芝加哥被捕的那个嬉皮士，你知道
know, at the convention, was hosting this business network in salons, like, you know, at Studio 54 by 1980, and the commune became the condo. And the demand for personal liberation got seamlessly absorbed into the demand for personal economic freedom, which was what Reagan's pitch was. That's why it worked. And smaller groups, you know, the ones that Stuart Brand had called the new communalists, they took their cybernetic theories and their copies of the whole Earth catalog, and they went to Silicon Valley. And the... same people who had held up those punch card signs in Berkeley at 64 went on to reimagine the computer is the opposite of what they had protested. The computer was no longer the mainframe,
在大会上，到1980年，他在Studio 54等地方的沙龙里主持这个商业网络，公社变成了公寓。对个人解放的需求被无缝地吸收进了对个人经济自由的需求中，这正是里根的推销内容。这就是它有效的原因。而较小的群体，你知道，斯图尔特·布兰德称之为“新公社主义者”的那些人，他们带着他们的控制论理论和他们的《全球概览》副本，去了硅谷。而……在64年伯克利举起那些打孔卡牌子的同一个人，后来重新构想了计算机，认为它是他们所抗议的对立面。计算机不再是大型机，
crushing the individual. The computer was the personal microcomputer liberating the individual. And the network was no longer IBM. The network was the W-E-L, which brand launched in 1985 is one of the first online communities. These, they were basically list serves, you know, or if you're not as old as me, they were like forums. The forum is like the closest thing. There were these bulletin board systems that you would log on to and basically post stuff and talk to people out of the country,
压碎个人。计算机是解放个人的个人微型计算机。网络不再是IBM。网络是W-E-L，布兰德在1985年将其作为最早的在线社区之一推出。这些，它们基本上是邮件列表，你知道，或者如果你不像我这么老，它们就像论坛。论坛是最接近的东西。有这些公告板系统，你会登录进去，基本上发布东西，和国家以外的人交谈，
but you had to pick one to subscribe to and pay for. And, you know, the distance between the Grateful Dead and early Google is remarkably short. And a lot of people, the same people, walked in that pathway. And both believed that the network's inherently leveled power structures. But they were wrong about that. in ways that we're still paying for.
但你必须选择一个来订阅并付费。而且，你知道，感恩而死乐队和早期谷歌之间的距离非常短。许多人，同样的人，走上了那条道路。而且两者都相信网络天生就能拉平权力结构。但他们在这一点上错了，其方式是我们至今仍在为此付出代价。
Because those hippie communes, a lot of the language that was used to sell bulletin boards and systems and these early networked computers, it was the same network, it was the same language of the commune, except you could do it from your basement when your kids were asleep. And, you know, you had to spend about the cost of a helicopter to get one until the price came down. But it was something that was familiar to the culture.
因为那些嬉皮公社，许多用来推销公告板和系统以及这些早期联网计算机的语言，都是同一个网络，都是同一个公社的语言，只是你可以在孩子们睡着时在地下室里做这件事。而且，你知道，你必须花费大约一架直升机的成本才能得到一台，直到价格降下来。但这是文化所熟悉的东西。
It didn't feel different, but it was different. And a lot of these people who went into cybernetics and, you know, sold their, you know, whole earth catalog, but had learned all of this, you know, kind of great engineering stuff, went to work at Lockheed. And that sounds like a joke, but, I mean, you can look at these demo shifts. Like many of the countercultures participants had advanced degrees in physics and engineering, because they were into ecology, essentially. And when the draft ended, when the moral stigma softened, the defense industry offered the most complex technical problem in the world to solve and the most money to solve it. And it didn't really care about your politics. You didn't have to make that distinction. You know, the Skunk Works division that built the SR 71 Blackbird and the F-1-17, you know, stealth fighter.
它感觉并不不同，但它确实不同。许多进入控制论的人，你知道，卖掉了他们的，你知道，《全球概览》，但已经学会了所有这些，你知道，某种伟大的工程学东西，去洛克希德工作了。这听起来像个笑话，但是，我的意思是，你可以看看这些人口统计学的转变。就像许多反文化参与者拥有物理学和工程学的高级学位，因为他们本质上喜欢生态学。当征兵结束，当道德污名软化时，国防工业提供了世界上最复杂的技术问题来解决，并提供了最多的钱来解决它。而且它并不真正关心你的政治。你不需要做出那种区分。你知道，制造SR-71黑鸟和F-117，你知道，隐形战斗机的臭鼬工厂部门。
They needed these brilliant minds. And, you know, their hair came off and the white coat went on. And the same people who had organized the teachings against the war were by the mid-80s, you know, working on propulsion systems for weapon systems, having compartmentalized the work into something that they could live with. So when you see a candidate like RFK where it's like people who have, you know, people who have. like him are like usually like working in huntsville for like a military contractor or a rocket company but then they also like are super into like vitamins and they like like like high tech but they also like view themselves as like agrarian and natural and against the system that is the last vestiges of these guys you know others you know probably the smallest group it's still a pretty big chunk they went to work in
他们需要这些聪明的头脑。而且，你知道，他们的头发剪掉了，白大褂穿上了。那些组织反战教学的人，到80年代中期，你知道，正在为武器系统研究推进系统，将工作细分成了他们可以接受的东西。所以当你看到像小罗伯特·肯尼迪这样的候选人时，就像人们，你知道，人们喜欢他，通常就像在亨茨维尔为像军事承包商或火箭公司工作，但他们也超级喜欢像维生素，他们喜欢像高科技，但他们也把自己视为像农业和自然，反对系统，那是这些家伙的最后残余，你知道，其他人，你知道，可能是最小的群体，它仍然是一个相当大的部分，他们去工作在
the oil fields in 1973 the embargo created these massive labor demand you know for this domestic oil extraction because it wasn't coming from other countries. We've got to get it here. And so the oil patch paid really well if you didn't have one of these technical degrees or you weren't particularly gifted a STEM field. And it didn't require any corporate polish. It stuck, you know, your sort of a badass rogue, rambler, a lone, every man, hardworking, you know, individual.
1973年的油田，禁运创造了这些巨大的劳动力需求，你知道，为了这种国内石油开采，因为它不是来自其他国家。我们必须在这里得到它。所以油田支付得非常好，如果你没有这些技术学位之一，或者你在STEM领域不是特别有天赋。而且它不需要任何企业修饰。它坚持，你知道，你那种坏蛋流氓、漫游者、孤独者、普通人、勤奋的，你知道，个人。
It fit that archetype pretty well. And so there's kind of funny stories. where, you know, a lot of these people are watching basically like hippies, either put their hair under a baseball cap or cut it off and switch the tie-dye for plaid or put the platt over the tie-dye and start working these oil rigs. And, you know, you call the place where you link basically like an oil extractor. Like you call it a joint, they're huge, these huge machines. And so there was like a joke in these towns where they were like, yeah, the hippies heard
它非常符合那个原型。所以有一些有趣的笑话，你知道，许多这些人看着基本上像嬉皮士，要么把头发藏在棒球帽下，要么剪掉它，把扎染换成格子，或者把格子穿在扎染上，开始在这些石油钻井平台上工作。而且，你知道，你把基本上像石油提取器的地方称为，你知道，一个关节（joint），它们很大，这些巨大的机器。所以这些城镇里有一个笑话，他们说，是的，嬉皮士听说
that we have 50-foot joints. You know, it's the tool, anyway, but you don't have to, the, the, the joint is a tool pusher. But, you know, it was this kind of joke that these towns were now being populated by, you know, in these sort of rural, a lot of times, conservative communities that had seen themselves, you know, against the hippie movement, were now being populated by them, and they couldn't really tell themselves apart from them. And the generation that had celebrated the first Earth Day became the labor force of the fossil fuel regime.
我们有50英尺长的关节。你知道，它是工具，无论如何，但是你不必，那个，那个，关节是工具推动者。但是，你知道，这是一种笑话，这些城镇现在被，你知道，在这些某种农村，很多时候，保守的社区里，他们曾把自己视为，你知道，反对嬉皮运动，现在被他们填满了，他们无法真正把自己和他们区分开来。而庆祝第一个地球日的那一代人成为了化石燃料政权的劳动力。
But none of these things, the point of this is that none of these things, of these things felt like a contradiction. They were pretty natural evolution. Um, because none of these guys understood systems pretty well. I mean, very well at all. And, you know, we have the benefit of hindsight. Um, but this just felt like the next thing. It didn't feel like a different thing. And many of these other people, you know, kind of the fourth that's left, they went to the woods. They became these back to the land movements. Um, and a lot of times they were rebelling against the excesses of the cities. You know, they didn't like the hard drugs.
但这些事情中没有一件，重点是这些事情中没有一件感觉像是矛盾。它们是相当自然的演变。嗯，因为这些家伙中没有一个人非常了解系统。我的意思是，一点也不了解。而且，你知道，我们有事后诸葛亮的优势。嗯，但这只是感觉像是下一件事。它感觉不像是一件不同的事情。而许多这些其他人，你知道，剩下的四分之一，他们去了森林。他们变成了这些回归土地运动。嗯，很多时候他们是在反抗城市的过度。你知道，他们不喜欢硬毒品。
They didn't like the heroin. And so they sort of became like conservative hippies. A lot of the back to the landers were either very religious or socially conservative. You know, in the Ozarks alone, there's 2,000 migrants that arrive there. And most of them are white. Most of them are under 30. Most of them have undergraduate degrees. And they buy these 90 acre parcels with year-round springs for under $20,000.
他们不喜欢海洛因。所以他们有点变成了像保守的嬉皮士。许多回归土地者要么非常虔诚，要么在社会上保守。你知道，仅在欧扎克地区，就有2000名移民到达那里。他们大多数是白人。他们大多数在30岁以下。他们大多数拥有本科学位。他们以不到2万美元的价格购买了这些带有全年泉水的90英亩地块。
And, you know, if you had to know how to do that, you know, kind of ecology stuff, not the STEM knowledge, and maybe not the ability to work on an oil rig, that was a pretty good deal. And so the story gets kind of dark there because that back to the land movement made these kind of weird outcomes. You know, one stream became modern organic farming. Something like woof, if you ever thought about organizing or, you know, going to volunteer at the World Organization of Organic Farmers when you were in college, you know, in between a year or something.
而且，你知道，如果你必须知道如何做那种，你知道，某种生态学的东西，而不是STEM知识，也许没有在石油钻井平台上工作的能力，那是一个相当不错的交易。所以故事在那里变得有点黑暗，因为那种回归土地运动造成了这些奇怪的结果。你知道，一条流变成了现代有机农业。像WOOF这样的东西，如果你曾经想过组织，或者，你知道，在大学时去世界有机农民组织做志愿者，你知道，在一年左右的时间里。
And, you know, but after the farm crisis of the 80s and there's decades of rural, you know, isolation. It kind of curdled into this weird survivalist pipeline. And that's why, like, now, you know, you associate conspiracy theories with generally the right wing, where in the 90s, when I was growing up, you know, Alex Jones and a lot of these guys, they were seen as, you know, these kind of hold out against the government communities. They were all seen as left wing. They were seen as sort of like extreme liberals because those core tenets of distrust, deep distrust of government, desire for autonomy, rejects. of industrial capitalism, self-reliance.
而且，你知道，但在80年代的农场危机之后，有几十年的农村，你知道，孤立。它有点凝结成了这种奇怪的生存主义管道。这就是为什么，像现在，你知道，你把阴谋论通常与右翼联系起来，而在90年代，当我长大时，你知道，亚历克斯·琼斯和许多这些家伙，他们被视为，你知道，这些某种反对政府社区的坚持者。他们都被视为左翼。他们被视为某种像极端自由派，因为那些对政府的不信任、极度不信任、对自主权的渴望、拒绝的核心原则。
They turned out to be ideologically, you know, pretty fluid. There was a lot of rural desperation mixed with, you know, whatever is left over from the roaring 60s. And so some former hippies evolved into these fierce anti-government survivalists and basically started, you know, kind of sovereign citizen-type movements. And researchers now call that the kind of crunchy to alt-right pipeline. But that's sort of the formula for what we have now. And, you know, when I was a kid, those guys were seen as left wing. You know, they were the ones, you know, talking about UFOs and the JFK assassination and everything.
工业资本主义，自力更生。事实证明，它们在意识形态上，你知道，相当流动。有很多农村的绝望与，你知道，从咆哮的60年代剩下的任何东西混合在一起。所以一些前嬉皮士演变成了这些激烈的反政府生存主义者，并基本上开始，你知道，某种主权公民类型的运动。研究人员现在称之为那种“脆皮到另类右翼”的管道。但这基本上就是我们现在所拥有的公式。而且，你知道，当我还是个孩子时，那些家伙被视为左翼。你知道，他们是那些，你知道，谈论不明飞行物和肯尼迪遇刺案以及所有事情的人。
And that was seen as a lefty thing. Now it's largely, you know, not. And so the, and it'll come back around. I'm not picking on anybody. So, you know, the culture didn't really die. It dispersed. And the pattern of the dispersal tells you why Reagan won in a 44 state landslide and why the Efficiency Gospel found no or.
那被视为一种左派的东西。现在它在很大程度上，你知道，不是了。所以，而且它会转回来。我不是在针对任何人。所以，你知道，文化并没有真正死亡。它分散了。而分散的模式告诉你为什么里根在44个州以压倒性优势获胜，以及为什么效率福音没有找到或。
organized resistance in the field that should have, you know, resisted at the hardest. Because the counterculture was never, you know, really collectivist. It was hyper individualistically, we talked about before, Sam Bingley. You know, it rejected the communal obligations of the mid-century welfare state in favor of personal liberation. And once the left-wing political project collapsed in the mid-70s, the demand for personal liberation was absorbed wholesale by a political right that offered personal economic freedom as a substitute. And neoliberalism thrived. you know, precisely because it could absorb the hippies' hatred of bureaucracy in the state and repackaged it as free market deregulation, but they didn't feel like they were switching
在应该，你知道，最坚决抵抗的领域里有组织的抵抗。因为反文化从来不是，你知道，真正的集体主义。它是超个人主义的，我们之前谈过，萨姆·宾利。你知道，它拒绝了世纪中叶福利国家的公社义务，转而支持个人解放。一旦左翼政治项目在70年代中期崩溃，对个人解放的需求就被一个提供个人经济自由作为替代品的政治右翼全盘吸收了。而新自由主义蓬勃发展。你知道，正是因为它能吸收嬉皮士对官僚机构和国家的仇恨，并将其重新包装为自由市场放松管制，但他们并不觉得自己在转换
sides or doing something different. You know, as Reagan would say, I didn't leave the Democratic Party. The Democrats left me. The Age of Aquarius did not defeat the establishment. It updated the establishment's operating software. And it's worth pointing out that, like, a lot of the, we view the hippies in retrospect as being very, like, left-leaning. a lot of these guys were not political
立场或做不同的事情。你知道，正如里根会说的，我没有离开民主党。是民主党离开了我。水瓶座时代并没有击败建制派。它更新了建制派的操作系统。而且值得指出的是，像，很多，我们回顾性地认为嬉皮士是非常，像，左倾的。这些人中很多并不是政治性的
and they were not bright. Like if you want to look at kind of like the vibe of this time, probably one of the stupidest books ever written is Jonathan Seagull, or what is it? Jonathan Livingston Seagull. It's like a Seagull doing Buddhism and being like, oh, I'm ostracized by the flock because I want to fly high for the spirit of it to better myself,
而且他们并不聪明。就像如果你想看看这种时间的某种氛围，可能写过的最愚蠢的书之一是《乔纳森·利文斯顿的海鸥》，或者是什么？乔纳森·利文斯顿海鸥。这就像一只海鸥在做佛教，并且像，哦，我被鸟群排斥了，因为我想为了精神而飞得高，为了提升自己，
but they want to fly low down and they want to pull me down and judge me, but then I will have a try, whatever. that culture is a whole lot of the vibe of this time. And so, you know, when Reagan's giving a speech about government being the problem, he's not saying something alien to the Berkeley generation. He was saying something that fit exactly inside the vocabulary that they had just spent a decade building. And speaking to the frustration that they're feeling about the bureaucracy,
但他们想飞得低，他们想把我拉下来评判我，但然后我会尝试，无论如何。那种文化是这个时代氛围的很大一部分。所以，你知道，当里根发表关于政府是问题的演讲时，他并没有说出对伯克利一代人来说陌生的东西。他所说的话正好符合他们刚刚花十年时间建立的词汇表。并谈到了他们对官僚机构感到的沮丧，
when Savio gives that speech. You know, they had said that the machine was the enemy. And he said that government. was the enemy. And they said that institutions were oppressive. And they said that regulations were oppressive. And they said that you liberate yourself by breaking free of those things. And, you know, Reagan was saying that a free market would liberate you. It was free. Let the market decide how much you're worth. So the punch card kids didn't really march against Reagan in 1980 because Reagan was telling them in the language that they had written that their old
当萨维奥发表那次演讲时。你知道，他们曾说机器是敌人。而他说政府。是敌人。他们说机构是压迫性的。他们说监管是压迫性的。他们说你通过打破这些东西来解放自己。而且，你知道，里根说自由市场会解放你。它是自由的。让市场决定你值多少钱。所以打孔卡的孩子们在1980年并没有真正反对里根，因为里根正在用他们写下的语言告诉他们，他们的旧
enemy was his old enemy, which wasn't, you know, quite true. But it was a lie in vocabulary that could no longer distinguish, you know, from the truth because the vocabulary was the same. You know, the semantics of these things felt very similar. But this is how the Overton windows shifts. Like, it's not really argument. It's vocabulary and exhaustion. And the people who built the vocabulary getting tired enough to let the next person come along and use it, you know, however they want, is generally how American culture works. That's why I'm spending so much time on these ideas in a psychotherapy podcast or what happened to psychotherapy podcast.
敌人是他的旧敌人，这并不，你知道，完全正确。但这是一个在词汇上的谎言，无法再区分，你知道，与真相的区别，因为词汇是一样的。你知道，这些东西的语义感觉非常相似。但这正是奥弗顿窗口移动的方式。就像，它不是真正的论点。它是词汇和疲惫。而那些建立词汇的人变得足够累，让下一个人来使用它，你知道，无论他们想要什么，这通常就是美国文化运作的方式。这就是为什么我在心理治疗播客或心理治疗发生了什么播客中花这么多时间谈论这些想法。
But this is the moment that American psychology gets its marching orders for the next 40 years. Because if the cultural project is now repression, the cultural project of psychology will also be repression. Or if it isn't, it's going to be at odds with the culture, but makes it hard for a, you know, bureaucracy to exist. that's codependent on the bureaucracy of the country. And so the country has decided not to look at what is wrong with it. The apparatus that was supposed to help us look at what is wrong
但这正是美国心理学在未来40年接到指令的时刻。因为如果文化项目现在是压抑，心理学的文化项目也将是压抑。或者如果不是，它将与文化不一致，但这使得，你知道，官僚机构难以存在。这与国家的官僚机构是共生的。所以国家决定不去看它有什么问题。本应帮助我们看清有什么问题的装置
will be repurposed to help us not look. To manage symptoms, to restore function, to get us back to work. That's what therapy was supposed to do. And the apparatus complied, not because anyone planned it, but because the incentive structures realigned overnight and a profession that had been desperately seeking legitimacy for a century found itself offered a new kind of legitimacy. If it would just stop asking certain questions,
将被重新利用来帮助我们不看。去管理症状，去恢复功能，去让我们回到工作岗位。这就是治疗本应做的事情。而装置顺从了，不是因为有人计划了它，而是因为激励结构在一夜之间重新调整，一个已经绝望地寻求了一个世纪合法性的职业发现自己被提供了一种新的合法性。如果它只是停止问某些问题，
and it did stop asking those questions, it could go ahead and be treated like a serious adult at the table, or so they thought. And this episode is about what happened there. You know, like I say in the beginning of all these, what psychology can see, what it can't see, and why it struggles to tell the difference. You know, it's about the wall that the wound speaks into,
而且它确实停止问那些问题，它可以继续被当作桌上严肃的成年人对待，或者他们是这么想的。而这一集就是关于那里发生了什么。你知道，就像我在所有这些开头说的那样，心理学能看到什么，不能看到什么，以及为什么它难以区分两者。你知道，它是关于创伤所说的墙，
or ran into. It's about bureaucratic apparatus, the diagnostic manual, the billing code. the 15-minute session and the closed committee room. How do we get from Freud's lifetime of psychoanalysis to 15 minutes and you're done? It's about a handful of decisions made by identifiable people and identifiable rooms in the late 70s and the early 80s that produced a system that even its own architects spent the rest of their lives apologizing for and largely trying to undo.
或者撞上的墙。它是关于官僚装置、诊断手册、计费代码。15分钟的会话和封闭的委员会会议。我们是如何从弗洛伊德一生的精神分析走到15分钟就结束的？这是关于70年代末和80年代初由可识别的人在可识别的房间里做出的少数几个决定，产生了一个连它自己的建筑师在余生中都在道歉并试图在很大程度上撤销的系统。
But they, the architect, were not as powerful as the machine anymore. And it's about a crucial bet that the profession of psychology made in the 90s that had it paid off, would have retroactively justified everything. But the bet was that the brain-mind problem was close to being solved, that human beings would behave like a machine. And so we could go ahead and preemptively structure, you know, it's not anti-scientific, it's just pre-scientific. The science will catch up to the direction that we're going,
但他们，建筑师，不再像机器那样强大了。这是关于心理学职业在90年代做出的一个关键赌注，如果它成功了，它将追溯性地证明一切。但赌注是脑-心问题即将被解决，人类会像机器一样行事。所以我们可以继续先发制人地构建，你知道，这不是反科学，它只是前科学。科学会赶上我们正在前进的方向，
but we're not going in a non-scientific direction. That, you know, the biology of mental illness would be understood in time to save this diagnostic system that had been built on the promise of this biology. and they bet the field's future on a scientific development that they were sure was imminent and they were wrong. The biology did not arrive and the diagnostic systems that had been built on the expectation that it would arrive could not be unbuilt. And maybe it still can't. And that is the deepest reason that the apparatus, even now, even after its own scientific authority has been declared invalid, continues to operate. It's a cathedral built on a foundation that turned out not to exist.
但我们并没有朝着非科学的方向前进。那，你知道，精神疾病的生物学将在时间上被理解，以拯救这个建立在这种生物学承诺之上的诊断系统。他们把该领域的未来押在了一个他们确信即将到来的科学发展上，而他们错了。生物学没有到来，而建立在它会到来的预期之上的诊断系统无法被拆除。也许它仍然无法被拆除。这就是为什么该装置，即使在现在，即使在它自己的科学权威被宣布无效之后，仍然继续运作的最深层原因。它是一座建立在事实证明并不存在的地基上的大教堂。
And by the time anyone could prove that the foundations did not exist, the cathedral was already holding up too much weight, too much structural infrastructure to ever be demolished. Are you angel? Are you engine? Are you hunger? Are you light? I press my ear against your casing here. A heartbeat in the bite.
而当有人能证明地基不存在时，大教堂已经支撑了太多的重量，太多的结构性基础设施，以至于永远无法被拆除。你是天使吗？你是引擎吗？你是饥饿吗？你是光吗？我把耳朵贴在你的外壳上。咬合中的心跳。
Every little little gospel. Levy freeze a kind of sign If I crash here in your cradle, will you rewrite this Old design Gold machines You hump the space between Where's sweat on the screen Old machines
每一个小小的福音。征收冻结一种标志。如果我在这里撞进你的摇篮，你会重写这个旧设计吗？旧机器。你驼着空间，在屏幕上的汗水之间。旧机器。
Where's caught in your fever dream In 1973, David Rosenhan published a study in science called On Being Sane and Insane Places And the premise is very elegant, elegant, you know, it claimed that, you know, seven graduate school students of his, they presented themselves at 12 different psychiatric hospitals, reporting one single symptom, hearing a voice say the word thud. But once admitted, they would just immediately stop pretending that it was, you know, they were having any symptoms and they would just behave normally.
在你的狂热梦境中被捕获。1973年，大卫·罗森汉在《科学》杂志上发表了一项名为《在理智和疯狂的地方》的研究，前提非常优雅，优雅，你知道，它声称，你知道，他的七名研究生，他们在12家不同的精神病院展示自己，报告一个单一的症状，听到一个声音说“砰”这个词。但一旦被录取，他们就会立即停止假装，你知道，他们有任何症状，他们就会表现得正常。
And they were nevertheless held for an average of 19 days. And when they were diagnosed with schizophrenia, they were given antipsychotic medication. and the hospital had no ability to distinguish a sane person from the insane. And so Rosenhan's point was that when you make psychology just this subjective thing where these people pretend to be experts, you know, these people, some of them he worked with and didn't like, you know, wanted to kind of show the lie to their expertise, you know, he would just say, you know, hey, look, if I go in here, anything that I do in the self-sealed system, it can't prove that I'm not, I can't prove that I'm not insane.
尽管如此，他们平均被关了19天。当他们被诊断出患有精神分裂症时，他们被给予了抗精神病药物。而医院没有能力区分理智的人和疯狂的人。所以罗森汉的观点是，当你把心理学变成这种主观的东西，这些假装是专家的人，你知道，这些人，其中一些他一起工作过且不喜欢，你知道，想展示他们专业知识的谎言，你知道，他只会说，你知道，嘿，看，如果我进去这里，我在这个自密封系统中做的任何事情，它都不能证明我不是，我不能证明我不是疯子。
Everything is self-reinforcing because it's just based on these experts who just kind of make things up. And so if I go in there and I act normally, everything that I will be doing in the medical record is going to be interpreted my normal behavior as abnormal behavior because it's all just vibes. So you can't tell the difference between a sane and an insane person. So why, you know, have psychiatrists. And the study was this giant bomb on the profession that it got cited everywhere and it was taught in every undergraduate
一切都是自我强化的，因为它只是基于这些基本上编造事情的专家。所以如果我进去那里，表现得正常，我在医疗记录中所做的一切都将被解释为我的正常行为是异常行为，因为这全都是氛围。所以你无法区分理智的人和疯狂的人。那么为什么，你知道，要有精神科医生。这项研究是对该职业的巨大炸弹，它到处被引用，并且在未来一代的每一门本科心理学课上都被教授。我的意思是，它教给我，而且它，你知道，所有这些记者都在报道这个，它确实让精神病学丢了脸，而且，你知道，后来当苏珊·卡拉汉在写她的书《伟大的伪装者》时，她去试图找到这些人中的一些，并试图找到记录，她发现了罗森汉的记录，她发现，你知道，也许他编造了一些事情，而且那项研究的很多内容，你知道，现在可以公开批评。但重点是它让精神病学非常不安全。而且许多人，即使研究是假的，你知道，也知道罗森汉所说的是真的。所以，你知道，尴尬是非常真实的。
psychology class for the next generation. I mean it's taught to me and it was you know all of these journalists were reporting on this it really put egg on the face of psychiatry and you know later when Susan Callahan is writing on her book the great pretenders she goes and tries to find some of these people and tries to find the records and she finds Rosohans records and she discovers that you know maybe he made some things up and And a lot of that study is, you know, open for critique now. But the point of it is that it made psychiatry very insecure. And a lot of people, even if the study was fake, you know, knew that what Rosenhand was saying was true. And so, you know, the embarrassment was very real.
而且有更早的故事，由，你知道，像贝克和阿什这样的人完成，你知道，他们发表了。他们展示了精神科医生看着同一个病人时的一致率在非常大的类别上可能低至40%，比如焦虑或抑郁。而在具体的诊断上，他们在像，你知道，广泛性焦虑症这样的事情上的一致率可能只有20%。所以两名精神科医生检查同一个病人，他们自信地产生这两个不同的诊断，那不是一个科学系统。而且他们现在可以推荐两种不同的治疗方法，你知道，从，你知道，这些新的精神病药物，抗精神病药物。
And there's earlier stories done by, you know, people like Beck and Ash, you know, they'd published. And they'd shown that the agreement rate between psychiatrists looking at the same patient could be as low as 40% on really big categories, like anxiety or depression. and on specific diagnoses, they could be 20% in agreement on something like, you know, generalized anxiety disorder. And so two psychiatrists that examine the same patient, and they confidently produce these two different diagnoses, that's not a scientific system. And they could recommend two different treatments now evolving, you know, from, you know, these new psychotics, antipsychotic drugs.
还有更早期的研究，比如贝克（Beck）和阿什（Ash）等人发表的研究。他们表明，精神科医生在评估同一位患者时，对于焦虑或抑郁等大类别的诊断一致率可能低至40%。而在针对特定诊断时，比如广泛性焦虑障碍，他们的一致率可能只有20%。因此，如果两位精神科医生检查同一位患者，却自信地给出了两种不同的诊断，这显然不是一个科学的系统。而且他们现在可能会推荐两种不同的治疗方案，比如使用这些新型抗精神病药物。
You know, they could prescribe two different medications based on which psychiatrist you And a lot of these things have serious side effects. They're dangerous drugs if you're giving them to the wrong person. So the Rosenhan study was just holding up a lie to this thing that the profession already knew. And that's why it took off. And the profession was also in this panic because at that same moment, the Rose Enhan's publishing, you know, the insurance industry was starting to ask, like, why should we reimburse for this at all? You want to talk to these people for 25 years.
你知道，根据你找的心理医生不同，他们可能会开出两种完全不同的药物。而且其中许多药物都有严重的副作用。如果你给错了人，它们就是危险的药物。所以罗森汉恩实验只是揭露了该行业早已心知肚明的谎言。这就是它之所以能引起轰动的原因。当时整个行业也陷入了恐慌，因为就在罗森汉恩发表研究成果的同时，保险业开始质疑：我们为什么要为这种治疗买单？你们想跟这些人聊上25年。
That doesn't look like a medical service. They could just talk to someone else. So practitioners who couldn't agree on what they were treating. And behaviors, you know, started arguing that, you know, these behaviorists, they started arguing that the entire psychoanalytic enterprise was unscientific anyway. And you should just look at the behavior because why look at something slippery and fuzzy like emotion or, you know, whether or not they're happy or meaning. I mean, who cares about this stuff? Can they go to work?
这看起来不像医疗服务。他们完全可以去跟别人聊。于是，那些无法就治疗方案达成一致的从业者们，以及行为主义者们开始争论，他们认为整个精神分析事业本身就是不科学的。你们应该只关注行为，因为为什么要关注情绪这种模糊不清的东西，或者关注他们是否快乐、是否有意义呢？谁在乎这些？他们能去工作吗？
Can they do it? You meet criteria or not based on what you're actually doing, not on how you feel. And so they stop talking about emotion. If the emotion is important, it'll stop them from doing something important. You know, Thomas Zaz is also a psychiatrist, and he had published the myth of mental illness around this time. And he argued that, you know, the whole field was this moral system, but it was basically pretending to be a scientific one. But really it was about morality, because you're just saying, these people don't contribute or we don't like them or they live in a way that it's different from the mainstream. So they're crazy, not because of a biomedical or biological reason, but just the culture doesn't like them.
他们能做到吗？你是否符合标准取决于你实际在做什么，而不是你的感受。于是他们不再谈论情绪。如果情绪很重要，它会阻止他们做重要的事情。托马斯·萨兹也是一位精神科医生，他在那个时期出版了《精神疾病的神话》。他认为整个领域是一个道德体系，但它基本上是在假装成一个科学体系。但实际上它关乎道德，因为你只是在说，这些人没有做出贡献，或者我们不喜欢他们，或者他们的生活方式与主流不同。所以他们疯了，不是因为生物医学或生物学原因，而仅仅是因为文化不喜欢他们。
So we're making a moral judgment. And insane and insane, there really wasn't that much. science too, that you're emasquerading a moral system as a medical one. And drugs that are coming out right now, you know, after the first generation of thorazine, and you're getting second generation antipsychotics, they need diagnoses so that they can get FDA approval. How do we know if it treats it or not if we can't, you know, research? Same thing that affects the profession to today. And so if you don't have a diagnosis, you can't get someone to treat that diagnosis, you know, pay for it or prescribe a drug for it. And so, you know, you know, you, you know, you
所以我们是在做道德判断。而“精神错乱”这个词，其实并没有太多的科学依据，你只是把一套道德体系伪装成了医疗体系。当时刚问世的药物，你知道，在第一代氯丙嗪之后，出现了第二代抗精神病药物，它们需要诊断结果才能获得FDA批准。如果我们不能进行研究，我们怎么知道它是否有效呢？同样的事情至今仍影响着这个行业。所以如果你没有诊断结果，你就无法让别人去治疗那个诊断，你知道，支付费用或开药。所以，你知道，你，你知道，你
You needed these reliable things in order to keep the industry going. And drug money was just going to dry up, which the profession needed to be able to function in the hospital and justify its existence as someone who could do something other than talk. But at the same time, you have a schizophrenia epidemic in the 70s because, you know, you have heroin and you have trauma from Vietnam and you have homelessness. And you have all of these kids that are no longer smoking dirtweed. And they're on harder drugs. and they're becoming psychotic.
你需要这些可靠的东西来维持这个行业的发展。药物资金即将枯竭，而该行业需要能够在医院中发挥作用，并证明其作为一种除了谈话之外还能做点什么的职业的合理性。但与此同时，70年代出现了精神分裂症流行，因为有海洛因，有来自越南战争的创伤，还有无家可归者。而且有这么多孩子不再抽劣质大麻了。他们开始吸食更强力的毒品，并变得精神错乱。
And, you know, there's still some disagreement about how much of schizophrenia is genetic and how much of it is environmental. We know it's a little bit of both. But the people who had the genes were definitely during this time having the trauma, you know, activate. It's not the 50s anymore. And a lot of them have, you know, basically been in Vietnam watching their friends get killed. And now they're, they have PTSD and they're doing hard drugs and they're homeless. And so schizophrenia and the first generation antipsychotics at the same time as Rosenhan,
而且，你知道，关于精神分裂症在多大程度上是遗传的，在多大程度上是环境造成的，仍然存在一些分歧。我们知道两者都有。但在那个时期，那些携带基因的人确实经历了创伤的激活。现在已经不是50年代了。他们中的许多人基本上是在越南看着朋友被杀。现在他们患上了创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），吸食强力毒品，并且无家可归。所以精神分裂症和第一代抗精神病药物在罗森汉恩实验的同时出现，
And that really saves the profession too, which that's an under-discussed point because, you know, before that, psychiatrists were just seen as sort of like sedating housewives. You know, you're just giving the nervous housewives these pills that are functionally time-released alcohol. And now, but there's not really anything that you can do, like that a heart surgeon can. There's all this insecurity. And then what happens is that you have all of these studies that say, okay, these psychoanalysts sat with the people with schizophrenia and they talked to them and they these people were psychotic and
这确实也拯救了这个行业，这是一个被低估的观点，因为在那之前，精神科医生只是被视为某种给家庭主妇镇静的人。你知道，你只是给那些紧张的家庭主妇开这些药，它们在功能上就是定时释放的酒精。现在，并没有什么真正能做的事情，不像心脏外科医生那样。这里面充满了不安全感。然后发生的事情是，你有了所有这些研究，说，好吧，这些精神分析学家与精神分裂症患者坐在一起，他们与他们交谈，而这些人是精神病患者，并且
they came up with all these heady conceptualizations about how the psychosis was like an extended metaphor for trauma that happened to them as a child but then also the trauma was like um you know reactivated during vietnam and the hallucination is actually to this metaphor and people are like who cares you talk to them for two years and nobody got better this guy gave him a pill and all of a sudden the guy's putting down a sign that says that he's Napoleon um or the rebirth of jesus or something and he's putting on a tie and he's going to work and he's getting discharged from the hospital. And so finally there was something that psychiatry could do. So Robert Spitzer shows up in the middle of this crisis.
他们想出了所有这些高深的概念化理论，关于精神病如何像是一种对童年创伤的延伸隐喻，但同时这种创伤在越南期间又被“重新激活”了，幻觉实际上是对这种隐喻的回应。人们会说，谁在乎呢？你跟他们谈了两年，没人好转。这家伙给了他一颗药，突然之间，那个人放下了一个写着他是拿破仑或者耶稣转世之类的牌子，他系上领带，去工作，然后从医院出院了。所以终于有精神病学能做的事情了。于是罗伯特·斯皮策在这次危机中出现了。
And Robert Spitzer is a psychiatrist, but he was not really thought of as a clinician because he didn't particularly like to sit in rooms with people. He wasn't really curious about human nature. He didn't really like talking to anybody. He viewed people kind of more as obstacles to be fit into systems or to be overcome. And, you know, what Spitzer loved was classification and talks taxonomy, that, you know, science could talk about how animals evolve. It could talk about, like, all the different, you know, philologies of insects and how they're, you know, related. And, you know,
罗伯特·斯皮策是一位精神科医生，但他并不被认为是一名临床医生，因为他不太喜欢和人坐在房间里。他对人性并不怎么好奇。他其实不喜欢和任何人交谈。他把人看作是需要被纳入系统或被克服的障碍。而且，你知道，斯皮策热爱分类学，就像科学可以谈论动物如何进化一样。它可以谈论昆虫的所有不同分类学，以及它们是如何相关的。而且，你知道，
he loved the cold satisfaction of fitting these messy realities into clean categories. And so the American Psychiatric Association, APA, they asked him to chair the task force that would produce this third edition of the diagnostic and statistical manual. It's kind of a hell marry to try and get psychiatry back on track and get it, you know, accepted with the cool kids again. And so Spitzer, was looking for this model and he looked at Washington University in St. Louis. There's a group of psychiatrists that are led by Eli Robbins, Samuel Goose, George Winnicor. And they had spent, you know, these decades, or they had spent about 10 years trying to operationalize psychiatric diagnosis. They were called the St. Louis group. And in 1972,
他喜欢将这些混乱的现实纳入整洁类别的冷酷满足感。于是美国精神医学学会（APA）请他担任主席，负责编写第三版《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）。这就像是试图让精神病学重回正轨，并让它再次被主流认可的“万福玛利亚”式的一搏。所以斯皮策在寻找这个模型，他看向了圣路易斯的华盛顿大学。那里有一群由伊莱·罗宾斯、塞缪尔·古斯、乔治·温尼科尔领导的精神科医生。他们花了，你知道，这些几十年，或者说他们花了大约10年时间试图将精神病诊断操作化。他们被称为“圣路易斯小组”。而在1972年，
they had produced what came to be called the Fegner criteria, you know, after the author is John Fegner. So the Fegner criteria was this diagnostic checklist where there's five symptoms from this list that last for this amount of time, and that equals this diagnosis. And so the St. Louis group was deeply hostile to psychoanalysis, and they were really committed to a biomedical model of mental illness, which didn't exist yet. And they'd figured out how to make psychiatric diagnoses look like the rest of medicine, finally. You know, you do a blood test to find out which virus somebody has. And you do a tumor marker to find out if somebody has cancer. But there wasn't something like that for the brain.
他们制作了后来被称为“费格纳标准”的东西，以作者约翰·费格纳的名字命名。所以费格纳标准是一个诊断清单，如果清单上有五个症状持续了这段时间，就等于这个诊断。所以圣路易斯小组对精神分析非常敌视，他们非常致力于一种当时还不存在的生物医学精神疾病模型。他们终于弄清楚了如何让精神病诊断看起来像其他医学领域一样。你知道，你做血液检查来找出某人感染了哪种病毒。你做肿瘤标志物检查来找出某人是否患有癌症。但大脑并没有类似的东西。
You know, as Rosenhand approved, you could just go in and lie and you looked crazy. So Spitzer takes this idea and he runs with it. And the way that he ran with it tells you everything that you need to know about was about to happen. You know, he told participants that they couldn't leave. Like you literally would lock the door. They described it as typewriter parties. You know, he'd get people wine and genitonic and, you know, they'd be in his apartment. And he would just say, how long does anxiety be?
你知道，正如罗森汉恩所证明的，你只要进去撒谎，你看起来就疯了。所以斯皮策采纳了这个想法并付诸实践。他执行的方式告诉你所有你需要知道的关于即将发生的事情。你知道，他告诉参与者他们不能离开。就像你真的会锁上门一样。他们将其描述为“打字机派对”。你知道，他会给人们提供葡萄酒和金汤力，你知道，他们会在他的公寓里。他只会说，焦虑持续多久？
last and half the group says, well, it's got to be at least a month. And the other half says, no, it's got to be six months. And he says, no, you got to decide. And they get in a fight. And he won't let him leave. And then finally they're like, okay, fine, three months. You know, somebody else is like, I refuse. And they're like, okay, because of Bob, we got to do two months. All right, there, there you go. And, you know, one of the things that Spitzer did was force these people to actually talk about the diagnosis that they were giving. Because before that, they were all these, like, little kings in their kingdom that didn't really have to agree. So Spitzer put an end to that pretty fast. And this process has to tackle the entire scope of diagnosis. So it's like the first Webster's
最后，一半人说，嗯，至少得一个月。另一半人说，不，得六个月。他说，不，你们得决定。然后他们吵了起来。他不让他们离开。最后他们说，好吧，行，三个月。你知道，另一个人说，我拒绝。他们说，好吧，因为鲍勃，我们得定两个月。好了，就这样。而且，你知道，斯皮策所做的事情之一就是强迫这些人真正讨论他们给出的诊断。因为在那之前，他们都是各自王国里的小国王，并不真正需要达成一致。所以斯皮策很快就结束了这种情况。这个过程必须涵盖诊断的全部范围。所以这就像第一本韦氏
dictionary. Like it's not very good and they have to kind of, but unlike, you know, the Webster's dictionary, they have to move at light speed to get this done. Like there's a 40 minute period where Spitzer says, okay, brief psychosis, you know, brief reactive psychotic disorder or brief reactive of psychosis. You've got that, and that's where somebody is having psychosis just for a minute, and that goes away. And then you have a factitious disorder where they're basically lying about being psychotic. How do you tell the difference? And the people talk for about 30 minutes. He types on the keyboard, everything that they're saying. The last 10 minutes, he makes, I think, four total edits and then says, all right, there you go. There's your list. And they go through the
词典。它不是很好，他们必须有点，但与韦氏词典不同的是，他们必须以光速完成这项工作。比如有40分钟的时间，斯皮策说，好吧，短暂性精神病，你知道，短暂反应性精神病障碍或短暂反应性精神病。你有这个，这是某人只精神错乱了一分钟，然后就消失了。然后你有做作性障碍，他们基本上是在撒谎说自己精神错乱。你怎么区分？人们谈论了大约30分钟。他在键盘上打出他们所说的一切。最后10分钟，他做了我想总共四处修改，然后说，好了，就这样。这是你们的清单。他们就这样完成了
whole entirety of mental health diagnosis in that way. Some of them get a little bit more time than that. But big project real quick. And the criteria work, you know, in a specific narrow sense. You know, he's making a punch card now for the profession. Two psychiatrists can look at the same patient and they can apply the same checklist. And they would now arrive at the same diagnosis, supposedly. And so reliability in the early testing goes up because people are just reading the lists. So they're not really doing therapy.
整个心理健康诊断。其中一些人得到的时间稍微多一点。但这是一个大项目，很快就完成了。这些标准在特定的狭义范围内是有效的。你知道，他现在正在为这个行业制作一张打孔卡。两名精神科医生可以看同一个病人，他们可以应用同一个清单。他们现在应该会得出相同的诊断。所以可靠性在早期测试中上升了，因为人们只是在阅读清单。所以他们并没有真正进行治疗。
They're kind of testing out the system. And so this crisis is marked as solved and the profession was saved. in the eyes of the people doing this in the 70s. And so the DSM3 is published in 1980. There's 265 categories. There's 494 pages. It restructured American psychiatric practice within five years. But here's what Spitzer has done is solving a reliability problem.
他们是在测试这个系统。所以这场危机被标记为已解决，这个行业在70年代做这件事的人眼中被拯救了。于是DSM-3在1980年出版。有265个类别。有494页。它在五年内重组了美国精神病学的实践。但斯皮策所做的是解决了一个可靠性问题。
But he completely abandoned the validity problem. Yeah, they agree. But do they agree on something that's right? Reliability is the question of whether two clinicians agree about a diagnosis. but validity is the question of whether the diagnosis corresponds to anything that is actually real, right? If I say everyone who has a blue shirt but also owns a blue of bare pants that they may or may not be wearing and drives a car is now defines as a yabula, then I've just made up a category. But that isn't really a very useful category because that's a thing that I just made up.
但他完全放弃了有效性问题。是的，他们达成了一致。但他们达成一致的东西是对的吗？可靠性是关于两名临床医生是否对诊断达成一致的问题，但有效性是关于诊断是否对应于任何实际存在的东西的问题，对吧？如果我说每个穿蓝色衬衫但同时也拥有一条蓝色裤子（无论他是否穿着）并开车的人现在被定义为“雅布拉”，那么我就编造了一个类别。但这并不是一个非常有用的类别，因为那是我刚刚编造的东西。
And psychiatry had inherited a lot of things that before this time people had just made up and then written a book on. And so you're not really measuring depth and meaning of a person's despair or even a purpose of how this diagnosis is going to be used. You've just measured five out of nine items on a checklist. And you've reduced the profession to essentially that. And the DSM3 was, you know, supposed to be a theoretical. That's what Spitzer was really proud of. You had all these people that were different schools of thought. And they wanted to come together at a conference and they wanted to fight.
而精神病学继承了许多在此之前人们只是编造出来然后写成书的东西。所以你并没有真正衡量一个人绝望的深度和意义，甚至没有衡量这个诊断将如何被使用的目的。你只是测量了清单上九项中的五项。你基本上把这个行业简化成了那样。而DSM-3，你知道，本应该是理论中立的。这就是斯皮策真正引以为豪的地方。你有所有这些来自不同思想流派的人。他们想在会议上聚在一起，他们想打架。
And they wanted to say, my school of thought is better. We should move past Freud. My school of thought is better. We should move back to Freud who was going deep. My school of thought is better. I'm a behaviorist. We shouldn't talk about emotion at all. And Spitzer had no interest in the messiness of those fights.
他们想说，我的思想流派更好。我们应该超越弗洛伊德。我的思想流派更好。我们应该回到深入研究的弗洛伊德那里。我的思想流派更好。我是行为主义者。我们根本不应该谈论情绪。而斯皮策对那些争吵的混乱毫无兴趣。
He wanted to sit these people down and say, yeah, who cares about Freud? Who cares about behavior? Which one of these boxes would you check if you were going to give somebody that thing? And then force them to agree. And he did. So, you know, it would describe symptoms and group them into diagnoses or diagnoses. And, you know, this was supposed to be this great virtue, the thing that allowed psychiatrists of all theoretical orientations to use without having anyone really win a fight. But what it actually did was hide an enormous theoretical commitment behind a claim of neutrality.
他想让这些人坐下来，说，是的，谁在乎弗洛伊德？谁在乎行为？如果你要给某人那个东西，你会勾选这些框中的哪一个？然后强迫他们达成一致。他做到了。所以，你知道，它会描述症状并将它们归类为诊断。而且，你知道，这本应该是这种伟大的美德，让所有理论取向的精神科医生都能使用，而不需要任何人真正赢得争论。但它实际上所做的是在一种中立性的主张背后隐藏了巨大的理论承诺。
Because by reducing diagnosis to symptom counting, it implicitly committed to a model, a biomedical model, where this symptom is now the disease. and where the question of why symptoms exist, you know, where it comes from, what its particular purpose is in a person's life, is it normal for most people to have it? Well, if most people have it and it's all around a life transition, can you call it a disease? You know, the history and the body and the meaning, it's just officially declared irrelevant to clinical care. And so the wound was no longer going to be something that was analyzed or understood or even looked at. It was just going to be something that affected the checkboxes that we ticked. And here's this thing about when you do that.
因为通过将诊断简化为症状计数，它隐含地承诺了一种模型，一种生物医学模型，其中这种症状现在就是疾病。而关于症状为什么存在的问题，你知道，它来自哪里，它在一个人生命中的特定目的是什么，大多数人有这种症状正常吗？嗯，如果大多数人都有它，而且它发生在人生转折点周围，你能称之为疾病吗？你知道，历史、身体和意义，它只是被正式宣布与临床护理无关。所以伤口不再是需要被分析、理解甚至审视的东西。它只是会影响我们勾选的复选框的东西。关于当你这样做时，有这样一件事。
Once that diagnosis is a checkbox, the treatment can also be a checkbox. So you've now manualized mental health in a way where if the patient does these things, the clinician does this, and that's therapy. And so it started to turn the psychiatrist into a machine. Once the diagnosis is a category, that can be reliably reproduced across clinicians. The treatment can be a protocol that can be reliable. liably reproduced across clinicians that feel scientific. And once treatment is now a protocol, it can be measured.
一旦诊断成为一个复选框，治疗也可以是一个复选框。所以你现在以一种方式将心理健康手册化了，如果病人做了这些事情，临床医生就做这个，这就是治疗。所以它开始把精神科医生变成一台机器。一旦诊断成为一个可以在临床医生之间可靠复制的类别。治疗可以是一个可以在临床医生之间可靠复制的协议，这感觉很科学。一旦治疗现在是一个协议，它就可以被测量。
And once it's measured, it can be reimbursed. And once it can be reimbursed, the insurance company has the leverage to dictate which treatments will be paid for. And once the insurance company has that leverage, the only treatments that survive are the ones that can be standardized into a protocol. And so the DSM3 didn't just save the profession. It rewrote the profession. And it mandated what the profession was allowed to be from the system.
一旦它被测量，它就可以被报销。一旦它可以被报销，保险公司就有杠杆来决定哪些治疗将被支付。一旦保险公司有了那个杠杆，唯一能存活下来的治疗就是那些可以标准化为协议的治疗。所以DSM-3不仅拯救了这个行业。它重写了这个行业。它规定了这个行业被系统允许成为什么。
that moment in time onward. But clinical infrastructure is not the only thing changing because Reagan has just been elected and Thatcher's been elected in Britain. So, you know, the other half is the financial infrastructure for therapy and psychology. Something that other professions like heart surgery don't really have to think about, something that the military doesn't really have to, if they want a whole bunch of money for bombs, they just tend to get it in America. Psychology does not work that way. And so the story of the financial infrastructure is kind of a funny catastrophe. in American medicine. It's darkly funny, but it's the story of this country that's now so committed to the mythology of the free market that it couldn't see that what it was constructing was one of the
从那一刻起。但临床基础设施并不是唯一在改变的东西，因为里根刚刚当选，撒切尔夫人在英国也当选了。所以，你知道，另一半是治疗和心理学的金融基础设施。这是心脏外科等其他行业不需要真正考虑的事情，也是军队不需要真正考虑的事情，如果他们想要一大笔钱买炸弹，他们在美国往往就能得到。心理学不是那样运作的。所以金融基础设施的故事在美国医学中是一种有趣的灾难。这很有黑色幽默，但这是这个国家的故事，它现在如此致力于自由市场的神话，以至于它看不出它正在构建的是
largest centrally planned price-setting bureaucracies in the developed world to this day, while telling itself that this was the opposite of central planning. In 65, you know, Lyndon Johnson signs Medicaid or Medicare into law. And so suddenly the federal government is paying for the medical care of every American over 65. So the question immediately arises, what does the government pay for each procedure? Because what they were asking us to pay is exorbitant. And so in a centrally planned system, the answer is pretty obvious. The government, you know, after consulting experts, it would just set a price. And this is what happens in every other developed country. You know, the state just has a price list for care. Knee surgery should cost the same thing. If you're charging
迄今为止发达国家中最大的中央计划价格设定官僚机构之一，同时还告诉自己这与中央计划相反。在65年，你知道，林登·约翰逊签署了医疗补助或医疗保险法案。所以突然间，联邦政府正在为每个65岁以上的美国人的医疗护理买单。所以问题立即出现，政府为每个程序支付多少钱？因为他们要求我们支付的价格是过高的。所以在一个中央计划系统中，答案是显而易见的。政府，你知道，在咨询专家后，它只会设定一个价格。这就是每个其他发达国家发生的事情。你知道，国家只是有一份护理价格表。膝盖手术应该花费相同的钱。如果你收费
too much, you're not doing knee surgery efficiently enough or something. You know, so doctors just get paid the price. But the American medical establishment had just spent the previous half century terrified that any government involvement in health care would lead to socialized medicine, communism, you know, which they understood as this existential threat to their existence. And a lot of the new myth of the morning in America was about a free market. So the American Medical Association had just, you know, they killed Truman's National Health Insurance Plan in the late 40s, you know, by spending what was, you know, then the largest lobbying budget in American history ever and saying that they were fighting Bolshevism in America. And a lot of this stuff gets talked about like the 80s because the 80s is kind of where it
太高了，说明你做膝盖手术的效率不够高之类的。你知道，所以医生只是得到那个价格。但美国医学界刚刚花了过去半个世纪的时间，担心任何政府对医疗保健的参与都会导致社会化医疗、共产主义，你知道，他们将其理解为对其存在的这种生存威胁。而许多关于“美国早晨”的新神话都是关于自由市场的。所以美国医学会刚刚，你知道，他们在40年代末扼杀了杜鲁门的国家健康保险计划，你知道，通过花费当时美国历史上最大的游说预算，并声称他们是在美国打击布尔什维克主义。而很多这些东西被谈论得像80年代，因为80年代是某种
comes to a head. But it starts way earlier with the Cold War. Like in 61, Medicare is still just a proposal. It's not a law yet. And the bill that's on the table is actually called the King Anderson bill, which is a Kennedy administration effort. And that's how far it goes back to provide federally funded health insurance for elderly people. So the American Medical Association is viscerally opposed.
达到顶峰的地方。但它早在冷战时期就开始了。比如在61年，医疗保险仍然只是一个提案。它还不是法律。桌上的法案实际上被称为“金-安德森法案”，这是肯尼迪政府的一项努力。这就是它追溯到多远，为老年人提供联邦资助的健康保险。所以美国医学会是本能地反对的。
And they've been opposing federal health insurance since the 30s. And so since FDR first even talks about that as being part of Social Security. And that had, you know, that was killed. They made sure that Truman's, you know, national health insurance proposal in the late 40s is killed by spending, you know, at the time, what is really the most amount of money that's ever been spent on any of this stuff when you look at inflation. But in 1961, they had a well-developed playbook for killing this federal health legislation, and they wanted to deploy that again. So the campaign that they run against the King Anderson bill is called Operation Coffee Cup.
而且他们从30年代就开始反对联邦健康保险。所以自从富兰克林·罗斯福第一次谈到将其作为社会保障的一部分。而那，你知道，那被扼杀了。他们确保杜鲁门在40年代末的国家健康保险提案被扼杀，通过花费，你知道，在当时，当你观察通货膨胀时，这确实是有史以来在这些事情上花费的最多的钱。但在1961年，他们有一套完善的剧本用来扼杀这种联邦健康立法，他们想再次部署它。所以他们针对金-安德森法案开展的运动被称为“咖啡杯行动”。
And it is even by the standards of the mid-century lobbying really weird. The American Medical Association hires Ronald Reagan, who at this point is just a fading B-movie actor who had done his last serious work in the 1950s. and he's now hosting the General Electric Theater on television. He's a spokesperson for corporations, which would be very useful to the corporations when he became a president because he knew how to sort of wander their talking points. And so Reagan had drifted from being this kind of New Deal Democrat in the 40s
即使按照世纪中叶游说的标准，它也非常奇怪。美国医学会聘请了罗纳德·里根，他此时只是一个正在褪色的B级片演员，他在1950年代完成了他最后一部严肃的作品。他现在正在电视上主持通用电气剧场。他是企业的发言人，当他成为总统时，这对企业非常有用，因为他知道如何以某种方式引导他们的谈话要点。所以里根从40年代那种新政民主党人
to being like a corporate spokesperson in the 50s and kind of a B actor. And then his politics had kind of followed that direction. And so he was known for being, you know, charming and telegenic and, you know, this conservative kind voice. and kind of grandfatherly even when he's younger. And so the AMA pays him to record LPs, like records, titled Ronald Reagan speaks out against socialized medicine.
变成了50年代的企业发言人，某种B级演员。然后他的政治倾向也随之发展。所以他以迷人、上镜和，你知道，这种保守的友善声音而闻名。即使在他年轻时也有一种祖父般的感觉。所以美国医学会付钱让他录制LP，就像唱片一样，标题是《罗纳德·里根反对社会化医疗》。
And it's approximately 10 minutes long. You can still find this audio on YouTube. This episode's longer, so I'm not going to clip as much. But on the record, you know, Reagan warns that if Medicare passes, it will lead to full socialized medicine, and that socialized medicine will lead to the end of American freedom itself. So the signature line that is on the record, You know, one of these days, you and I are going to spend our sunset years telling our children and our children's children what it once was like in America when men were free.
它大约有10分钟长。你仍然可以在YouTube上找到这段音频。这一集比较长，所以我不会剪辑那么多。但在唱片上，你知道，里根警告说，如果医疗保险通过，它将导致全面的社会化医疗，而社会化医疗将导致美国自由本身的终结。所以唱片上的签名台词是，你知道，总有一天，你和我将会在我们的晚年告诉我们的孩子和我们孩子的孩子，当人们自由时，美国曾经是什么样子。
Those are the stakes, you know, that still are, you know, a part of the system that affect psychotherapy and probably, probably worse than other professions. You know, and he says this about a bill that would provide hospital insurance for people over 65. So what's weird is that they sent all of this to doctor's wives because they know they kind of have the doctor's ear and they like like free things in the mail basically. But they also know that the wives get together and they play records at coffee gatherings and then they kind of get whipped up about politics. And so the doctor's wives essentially get these records in the mail. And then while they're having coffee like, oh, what is this? Let's put it on. and then get terrified and then talk to their husbands.
这就是赌注，你知道，这仍然是系统的一部分，影响着心理治疗，而且可能，可能比其他行业更糟糕。你知道，他针对一项将为65岁以上的人提供医院保险的法案说了这些话。所以奇怪的是，他们把所有这些都寄给了医生的妻子，因为他们知道她们有点能听到医生的心声，而且她们基本上喜欢邮件里的免费东西。但他们也知道妻子们聚在一起，在咖啡聚会上播放唱片，然后她们会被政治煽动起来。所以医生的妻子们基本上在邮件里收到了这些唱片。然后当她们喝咖啡时，比如，哦，这是什么？让我们放一下。然后感到恐惧，然后去和她们的丈夫谈。
So, yeah, that's Operation Coffee Cup. So, you know, when Medicare does pass, the costs do immediately explode because doctors aren't stupid. So the law says if Medicare will pay you what you say your usual rate is because we have a free market, you now just get to make your rate anything that you want and the government has to pay it. So the rate increase is just compound. You know, people start tripling the cost of what they're doing.
所以，是的，这就是咖啡杯行动。所以，你知道，当医疗保险确实通过时，成本确实立即爆炸了，因为医生并不傻。所以法律说，如果医疗保险将支付你所说的通常费率，因为我们有自由市场，你现在只需要把你想要的任何费率定为你的费率，政府就必须支付。所以费率的增加只是复合的。你知道，人们开始把他们所做的事情的成本增加两倍。
But again, you know, the project is the free market, this myth of a free market that is always better and more competitive than a fixed rate somehow. So now you're, this becomes a problem. So by the mid-80s, it becomes a fiscal emergency. And the country has a choice. You know, it could do what every other country had done, which was have the government set prices through transparent regulatory processes or just have people vote on it. Or it could keep pretending that it had a free market. in healthcare, even though there was no free market in healthcare because the patients couldn't shop and the prices were paid by a third party.
但同样，你知道，这个项目是自由市场，这种自由市场的神话，总是比固定费率更好、更有竞争力。所以现在你，这成了一个问题。所以到了80年代中期，它成了一个财政紧急情况。这个国家有一个选择。你知道，它可以做每个其他国家都做过的事情，那就是让政府通过透明的监管程序设定价格，或者只是让人们投票决定。或者它可以继续假装它在医疗保健领域有一个自由市场，即使医疗保健领域没有自由市场，因为病人无法购物，价格由第三方支付。
And because like healthcare in America, especially now, but even then, lacks any of the features of anything that you could remotely call a market. But they want to stop it. And so in 1989, Congress passed legislation creating the Medicare resource-based relative value scale, what would be called, what would eventually become the RUC or the RUC. So the idea was that. that instead of paying what doctors said was customary, Medicare would assign each medical procedure a score based on the resources required to perform it. So it makes sense, right? It's a centralized
而且因为像美国的医疗保健，尤其是现在，即使在当时，也缺乏任何你可以勉强称为市场的东西。但他们想阻止它。所以1989年，国会通过了立法，创建了医疗保险基于资源的相对价值量表，也就是后来被称为RUC或RUC的东西。所以这个想法是。而不是支付医生所说的习惯费用，医疗保险将根据执行程序所需的资源为每个医疗程序分配一个分数。所以这说得通，对吧？这是一个中央
planning without the centralized planning or oversight or democracy. But, you know, just you rank these things on time, skill, and then overhead. You need a $500 device to do it. How long does it take you to require the skills to do it? Is there a whole lot of risk where you need to cover liability insurance and then how much time. That should, you know, tell us what anything costs. So, you know, the score, which is called the relative value unit or RVU, like would be multiplied by a conversion factor to produce the Medicare payment. And so this would be this objective thing, you know, scientific and resource based. And the opposite of central planning, somehow, even though it was very obviously the central setting of prices for the largest healthcare market in the world, but it can't
计划，没有中央计划或监督或民主。但是，你知道，只是你根据时间、技能和间接费用对这些东西进行排名。你需要一个500美元的设备来做它。你需要多长时间才能获得做它的技能？是否有大量的风险需要你承担责任保险，然后需要多少时间。这应该，你知道，告诉我们任何东西的成本。所以，你知道，这个分数，被称为相对价值单位或RVU，就像会被乘以一个转换系数来产生医疗保险支付。所以这将是这个客观的东西，你知道，科学的和基于资源的。而且以某种方式与中央计划相反，即使它非常明显是世界上最大的医疗保健市场的中央价格设定，但它不能
look like that. And so here's another kind of weird thing is Congress is having created the system, and then they ask the question that every central planning bureaucracy has to answer, which is, like, who actually scores the procedures? And so the answer, because the AMA had spent 25 years, you know, building the lobbying infrastructure to ensure that this answer was that doctors were schooled their procedures. So Congress aren't doctors. You need a committee of the American Medical Association called the Specialty Society. relative value scale update committee or the Ruck and this is the modern iteration. So 31 specialists and they're almost all proceduralists.
看起来像那样。所以这里有另一种奇怪的事情，国会创建了这个系统，然后他们问每个中央计划官僚机构都必须回答的问题，那就是，谁实际上给程序评分？所以答案，因为美国医学会花了25年，你知道，建立游说基础设施以确保这个答案是医生给他们的程序评分。所以国会议员不是医生。你需要一个名为“专业协会”的美国医学会委员会。相对价值量表更新委员会或Ruck，这是现代迭代。所以31名专家，他们几乎都是程序操作者。
There's mainly, you know, high insurgents talking about a high end specialty, would meet three times a year in a hotel ballroom and they would assign these RVU scores to the procedure that their own specializations, you know, they would split the money up basically amongst their professions, their specializations. You know, the issue with that, though, is that no one really sees it and no one except for them has a whole lot of say. And Congress will go with their recommendation almost, I think it's like 93% of the time. Just almost all the time Congress will do whatever they say unless funding gets cut later and then they kind of have to play with it.
主要是，你知道，高水平的外科医生谈论高端专业，他们每年在酒店宴会厅开会三次，他们会把这些RVU分数分配给他们自己专业领域的程序，你知道，他们基本上会在他们的职业、他们的专业之间瓜分这笔钱。你知道，这其中的问题是，没有人真正看到它，除了他们之外，没有人有太多的发言权。而国会几乎会采纳他们的建议，我想大约是93%的时间。几乎所有时间国会都会做他们说的任何事情，除非资金后来被削减，然后他们不得不摆弄它。
But it's almost always just sort of a direct doctors are still telling Congress what to pay. The doctors are just keeping themselves in check because they really don't want the federal government to ever set rates still. So these deliberations are sealed. And that committee operates outside of the federal rulemaking committee that would require public, you know, comment or transparency or accountability. And so it's a private club of doctors who set prices that the federal government pays doctors. And the federal government, having outsourced the price setting, then enforces the prices through the largest healthcare payment system in the world. And private insurance, you know, pays attention to Medicaid rates because they have to make theirs competitive with that. And better than that, you know, so you would pay for private insurance.
但几乎总是医生仍然在告诉国会支付多少钱。医生只是在控制自己，因为他们仍然真的不希望联邦政府设定费率。所以这些审议是密封的。该委员会在联邦规则制定委员会之外运作，该委员会需要公众，你知道，评论或透明度或问责制。所以这是一个医生私人俱乐部，他们设定联邦政府支付给医生的价格。而联邦政府，在将价格设定外包后，通过世界上最大的医疗保健支付系统执行这些价格。而私人保险，你知道，关注医疗补助费率，因为他们必须使他们的费率与那个具有竞争力。而且比那个更好，你知道，所以你会支付私人保险。
And so that RUC effectively sets the price of every medical procedure in the country, which affects psychology and specifically psychotherapy in a strange way that a lot of people still don't understand. But that RUC being a committee of specialists and proceduralists, it has consistently scored procedures higher than evaluation. And, you know, if you know where I'm going with this, psychiatry and especially therapy like me, you know, we don't have a procedure, right? It's just talking. cataract surgery, an outpatient procedure that takes, you know, this competent ophthalmologist, 15 minutes, it's been valued at an effective hourly rate that is multiples of what a primary care doctor earns when they spend an hour with you, you know, coordinating the care of all the things in your life that you want to know before you say that somebody's healthy or unhealthy or make
所以那个RUC有效地设定了全国每个医疗程序的价格，这以一种许多人仍然不理解的奇怪方式影响着心理学，特别是心理治疗。但那个RUC作为一个专家和程序操作者的委员会，它一直给程序的评分高于评估。而且，你知道，如果你知道我要去哪里，精神病学，特别是像我这样的治疗，你知道，我们没有程序，对吧？这只是谈话。白内障手术，一个门诊程序，需要，你知道，这个称职的眼科医生，15分钟，它的价值是一个有效的时薪，是初级保健医生当你花一小时与你在一起时赚取的倍数，你知道，协调你生活中所有你想在说某人健康或不健康之前知道的事情，或者做出
a recommendation to change medication or behavior. You know, cardiac catheterization is generously reimbursed, but the hour of psychiatric evaluation is not. And you can do these procedures really quickly. And so it changes the profession where no one really wants to be a psychiatrist anymore. You want to go, you know, where the money is. And psychiatry and general practice medicine, which is what the majority of Americans will actually encounter in the health care system are the ones that get no money, no funding, and get covered up with bureaucracy. Whereas the people that do like some sort of high tech, you know, foot surgery or now like, you know, you shoot protons at a cancer tumor or something and you need a you know four million dollar device to do this
改变药物或行为的建议。你知道，心脏导管插入术得到了慷慨的报销，但一小时的精神病学评估却没有。而且你可以很快地做这些程序。所以它改变了这个行业，没有人真的想再做精神科医生了。你想去，你知道，钱在哪里。而精神病学和全科医学，这是大多数美国人实际上会在医疗保健系统中遇到的，是那些没有钱、没有资金、被官僚主义掩盖的领域。而那些做某种高科技的人，你知道，足部手术，或者现在像，你知道，你向癌肿瘤发射质子之类的，你需要一个，你知道，四百万美元的设备来做这个
they're sucking up the majority of the money and those things are important too but they're things that will not affect most americans will not affect most people and so you know that whole kind of arrangement is wild because you have conservative politicians who spend the 80s and 90s railing against the inefficiency of socialized medicine in europe you know uh you want socialized medicine you've got to play socialist taxes was always the line. And the British National Health Service, you know, and the Canadian system, they hate it. Let me come up with every, you know, problem that those things have. But the horror of letting the government set medical prices is something they're saying.
他们吸走了大部分资金，而这些事情也很重要，但它们是不会影响大多数美国人的事情，不会影响大多数人。所以，你知道，整个那种安排是疯狂的，因为你有保守派政治家，他们在80年代和90年代抨击欧洲社会化医疗的低效率，你知道，呃，你想要社会化医疗，你必须支付社会主义税，这总是那句台词。而英国国家医疗服务体系，你知道，和加拿大系统，他们讨厌它。让我提出所有，你知道，那些东西有的问题。但让政府设定医疗价格的恐怖是他们正在说的东西。
But meanwhile, the American government was setting medical prices for the largest health care market on Earth. And it was markedly less efficient than any of those systems. Again, not a political argument. This is just sort of a structural analysis of how we got here and how these things work. So it was doing through private committee, whose deliberations were sealed, whose membership was determined by professional politics, whose incentives were aligned with the specialties
但与此同时，美国政府正在为地球上最大的医疗保健市场设定医疗价格。而且它明显比那些系统中的任何一个效率都低。同样，这不是一个政治论点。这只是某种关于我们如何走到这一步以及这些事情如何运作的结构性分析。所以它是通过私人委员会做的，其审议是密封的，其成员资格由职业政治决定，其激励措施与专业领域一致
that benefited most, you know, the people who were clinging to an existing arrangement, the country had built this centrally planned price-setting bureaucracy and convinced itself it was a free market. When if this was not somebody making a recommendation to Congress, that Congress just followed, it would be by in any world a cartel. This is the definition of a cartel,
那些受益最大的，你知道，那些坚持现有安排的人，这个国家已经建立了一个中央计划的价格设定官僚机构，并说服自己这是一个自由市场。如果这不是某人向国会提出建议，而国会只是跟随，那么在任何世界里，它都会是一个卡特尔。这是卡特尔的定义，
but it isn't because it's separate. They just say, hey, do this and then Congress does it. So it's not a cartel because they're two separate organizations that this is the system, guys. So it got the inefficiency of a centrally planned economy combined with the lack of accountability of a private capture model. And it has the absence of any redistribution towards unmet need that you would expect a centrally planned system to provide.
但它不是，因为它被分开了。他们只是说，嘿，做这个，然后国会就做了。所以它不是一个卡特尔，因为它们是两个独立的组织，这就是系统，伙计们。所以它得到了中央计划经济的低效率，结合了私人捕获模式的问责制缺失。而且它缺乏任何你期望中央计划系统提供的对未满足需求的再分配。
And so the field that paid the highest price was psychiatry, because psychiatry eventually, you know, treats most people, or, you know, somebody that you know. And so almost every American will at some point in their life have a mental health episode that would benefit from some kind of careful evaluation. That doesn't mean that most Americans will seek it out, but data tells us that they probably should at some point. and they will need something that now the system will not pay for.
所以付出最高代价的领域是精神病学，因为精神病学最终，你知道，治疗大多数人，或者，你知道，你认识的人。所以几乎每个美国人一生中都会有某个时刻经历心理健康发作，如果能得到某种仔细的评估将会受益。这并不意味着大多数美国人会寻求它，但数据告诉我们，他们可能在某个时候应该这样做。而且他们将需要一些现在系统不会支付的东西。
And when the system would not pay for it, the system stopped providing it. And so the wait list for actual psychiatrists became years long. And sometimes. And the 15-minute med check became standard. Psychiatrists just in order to pay off the college loans that they had had to meet with you for 15 minutes. And so this whole category of presentation, anything that couldn't be reduced to a clean diagnostic checkbox and a correspondence. responding medication became uneconomic, which means that a lot of people don't do it anymore. And there was a lot of lost muscle memory.
当系统不支付它时，系统就停止提供它。所以实际精神科医生的等待名单变成了几年长。有时。而15分钟的药物检查成了标准。精神科医生只是为了偿还他们背负的大学贷款，不得不与你见面15分钟。所以整个这种表现类别，任何不能简化为干净的诊断复选框和相应的药物的东西都变得不经济了，这意味着很多人不再做它了。而且有很多丢失的肌肉记忆。
There was a lot of lost institutional knowledge after the 70s, which is why when you read therapy today, books published today, and there's some good ones, and you read therapy in the 1970s, it's sad. It's sad how much better they were at doing these things. The doctors and Congress had both set their own rates. and they'd done so behind a curtain of mythology that prevented anyone from noticing it. And the bureaucracy was the free market.
70年代后，大量机构知识流失了。这就是为什么当你阅读今天的治疗书籍——虽然其中不乏佳作——再对比70年代的治疗文献时，会感到悲哀。令人难过的是，他们当时在处理这些问题时竟是如此出色。医生和国会各自设定了自己的费率，并在一层神话的幕布后进行，这使得没人能察觉到这一点。而官僚机构本身就是自由市场。
And the free market was the bureaucracy. And the mythology was the bureaucracy. And so the cold machine was beginning to dominate the warm ghost. Fever dream. The third piece of the apparatus at this time is what the behaviorists were up to. And this is something that still affects
自由市场就是官僚机构，神话也是官僚机构。于是，冰冷的机器开始主宰温暖的灵魂。一场狂热的梦。当时这套机制的第三个组成部分是行为主义者的所作所为。这至今仍在影响着
psychotherapy today. I want to be clear when I'm talking about CBT because it's widely practiced and many therapists are trained in it and they're great clinicians who help people and I'm not arguing that CBT doesn't work because I do it, everyone does it. You know, it's just that when therapy
今天的心理治疗。在谈论认知行为疗法（CBT）时，我想明确一点：它被广泛应用，许多治疗师都受过相关培训，他们是优秀的临床医生，能够帮助人们。我并不是说CBT无效，因为我也在用，每个人都在用。你知道，问题在于当治疗
starts and stops there, you've made a horrible reduction of what psychology is. What I'm arguing is that the reason that CBT became the only thing that the apparatus could see at this point. Cognitive behavioral therapy was developed by Aaron Beck and Albert Ellis in the late 50s and 60s. And again, I'm not indicting these guys.
仅止步于此，你就对心理学进行了可怕的简化。我想说的是，CBT之所以在当时成为这套机制唯一能看见的东西，是有原因的。认知行为疗法是由亚伦·贝克（Aaron Beck）和阿尔伯特·埃利斯（Albert Ellis）在50年代末和60年代开发的。再次声明，我不是在指责这些人。
What I'm saying is that the success of CBT, and they were very lucky, you know, it became the only thing the apparatus could see. And the apparatus started actively preventing the development of anything that wasn't it, you know, for the next 30 years, at least. Some people tell me that that's actually not true anymore, the last 15, whatever, whatever.
我想说的是，CBT的成功——他们非常幸运——使它成为了这套机制唯一能看见的东西。在接下来的至少30年里，这套机制开始积极阻碍任何非CBT疗法的发展。有些人告诉我，这种情况现在已经不存在了，或者说过去15年里变了，随你怎么说吧。
I would just say call up 15 people and see what's on the front page of their website. But anyway, you know, the success of it has very little to do with whether or not it works. The success of it has to do with whether or not it can be measured. And CBT is designed for you to be able to measure things in the same way that the DSM3 was. So, you know, what Albert Ellis and Aaron Beck, you know, start doing. And Ellis is really more REBT, which is still kind of a copy. behavioral therapy. But what they're doing is saying this is just distorted thinking. It's just distorted thinking produces feelings that are distorted and then distorted behavior based on those feelings.
我只想说，你随便打给15个人，看看他们网站首页上写的是什么。但无论如何，你知道，它的成功与它是否有效关系不大，而与它是否可被衡量有关。CBT的设计初衷就是让你能像DSM-3那样去衡量事物。所以，你知道，阿尔伯特·埃利斯和亚伦·贝克开始做的事情——埃利斯更多是理性情绪行为疗法（REBT），这本质上也是一种认知行为疗法——他们所做的是指出：这只是扭曲的思维。扭曲的思维产生了扭曲的情绪，进而导致基于这些情绪的扭曲行为。
And so if you just look at all the places where somebody is thinking incorrectly, you can debug it. So if you can teach the patient to identify and correct the distorted thinking, the feeling and the behavior will follow after that, which is something that a lot of people do need. But again, that's not all psychotherapy is. You can't fit all of psychology into that framework. And so there's is a wisdom in that. You know, there are clinical situations where teaching someone to recognize a catastrophic thought as a catastrophic thought is genuinely useful that you're catastrophizing. This isn't real. It's something that you're just being afraid of because you know how to be anxious and so you're finding a way to make that anxiety happen. You know, Beck himself,
所以，如果你找出一个人思维不正确的所有地方，你就可以进行“调试”。如果你能教会患者识别并纠正扭曲的思维，情绪和行为就会随之改善，这确实是许多人所需要的。但再说一次，心理治疗不仅仅是这些。你无法将整个心理学塞进那个框架里。这种方法确实有其智慧之处。你知道，在某些临床情况下，教导某人将灾难化思维识别为灾难化思维是非常有用的，你会意识到：“我只是在灾难化，这不是真实的。这只是因为我知道如何焦虑，所以我正在寻找一种方式来制造这种焦虑。”你知道，贝克本人，
was a pretty thoughtful clinician and he never claimed that CBT was the only thing that worked. He was just sort of making a model that was more efficient than psychoanalysis and fit the time. And he understood, you know, what he was taking out when he was. simplified his model. He didn't think that the infrastructure would forget all of the things that weren't included in that model in the way that I would argue that they have today. But CBT had these three properties that made it a perfect fit for the apparatus of the time. First, it was time limited. A typical CBT protocol could be completed in eight sessions. Some of them are as long as 16, but they're generally pretty fast. And that fit insurance authorization periods because, well,
是一位相当有思想的临床医生，他从未声称CBT是唯一有效的疗法。他只是建立了一个比精神分析更高效、更符合时代需求的模型。他明白自己在简化模型时剔除了什么。他并不认为这套基础设施会像我今天所说的那样，遗忘掉模型中未包含的所有内容。但CBT具备三个特性，使其完美契合当时的机制。首先，它是限时的。一个典型的CBT方案可以在八次会谈中完成。有些长达16次，但通常都很快。这符合保险授权周期，因为，嗯，
you're going to do therapy. And if it's not done in 16 sessions, that's what the therapy was written to be done in. So then it didn't work. You need to assume that you didn't respond to the drug, the treatment. So, you know, second, it's manualizable. You could write a protocol that is specific and standardized. We have standardized diagnosis. Now we're standardizing care based on those diagnoses. So it specifies that what the therapist did in session one, session two, session three was all part of this intervention for the thing that you were treating. And so you could train a clinician to follow that protocol, and then you could have control over what everyone was doing. And so you could measure whether the clinician had followed the protocol.
你要进行治疗。如果16次会谈没完成，而治疗方案就是按16次写的，那说明它没效。你需要假设你对药物或治疗没有反应。所以，第二，它是可手册化的。你可以编写一个具体且标准化的方案。我们有了标准化的诊断，现在我们正基于这些诊断来标准化护理。它规定了治疗师在第一次、第二次、第三次会谈中做了什么，这些都是针对你所治疗问题的干预措施的一部分。因此，你可以培训一名临床医生遵循该方案，从而控制每个人的行为。这样你就可以衡量临床医生是否遵循了方案。
And third, it produced measurable symptom changes, supposedly. So if you administered the pHQ 9, which is a depression questionnaire before treatment, and then after treatment, you could see if the therapy had done anything. Now, granted, you're just looking for that one thing, but that's what we wanted to do at this time. This wasn't an analysis of the soul. It wasn't a reconfiguring of your values. It wasn't a construction of meaning. It was you have this one diagnosis.
第三，它产生了可衡量的症状变化，据说是这样。所以，如果你在治疗前使用PHQ-9（抑郁症问卷），然后在治疗后再次使用，你就能看出治疗是否起到了作用。当然，你只是在寻找那单一的东西，但这正是我们当时想做的。这不是对灵魂的分析，不是对价值观的重构，也不是对意义的构建。它只是：你有这一个诊断。
You want that one diagnosis treated. This is a protocol that treats that diagnosis. You completed the protocol. It either worked or it didn't. And we have nothing else for you if it didn't. And so, you know, here's where the academic apparatus, you know, got involved. Because the National Institute of Mental Health, which is the federal funding agency for psychiatric research, was simultaneously being reorganized around the same logic.
你想要治疗这一个诊断。这是一个治疗该诊断的方案。你完成了方案。它要么有效，要么无效。如果无效，我们对你别无他法。所以，这就是学术机制介入的地方。因为美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH），即联邦精神病学研究的资助机构，当时正同时围绕同样的逻辑进行重组。
You know, the funding criteria shifted to get a research grant. you needed to study an intervention with a clearly defined mechanism of action, a manualizable protocol and measurable outcomes. And the gold standard of evidence became the randomized controlled trial. So you could take 100 depressed patients and you could randomly assign them to receive either your protocol or a placebo, just kind of have them do random stuff. And then you could compare and see if the PHQ 9 scores at the end were better than doing random things.
你知道，资助标准发生了转变：要获得研究经费，你需要研究一种具有明确作用机制、可手册化方案和可衡量结果的干预措施。而证据的黄金标准变成了随机对照试验。你可以找100名抑郁症患者，随机分配他们接受你的方案或安慰剂，或者让他们做些随机的事情。然后你可以比较，看看结束时的PHQ-9分数是否比做随机事情更好。
And so the modalities that fit, you know, this template, they flourished. And CBT fit the template really well. And so DBT is another one. You started to see psychotherapy fit itself into this protocol in the new things that it was creating. Because if they couldn't fit in, they couldn't be studied, and then you could never say that they worked. And so anyone who did fit these manualizable treatments during this error, they got studied, they got published, and then they got cited. And they built up what looked like an enormous evidence base. And the evidence base that was used to argue that they were the only legitimate treatments for various conditions.
于是，符合这一模板的模式蓬勃发展。CBT非常契合这个模板。DBT（辩证行为疗法）也是如此。你开始看到心理治疗在它所创造的新事物中，主动将自己塞进这个方案里。因为如果它们不符合，就无法被研究，也就永远无法证明它们有效。因此，在那个时代，任何符合这些可手册化治疗的人，都得到了研究、发表和引用。他们建立起了一个看起来极其庞大的证据库。而这个证据库被用来论证它们是针对各种疾病的唯一合法治疗方法。
Anyone else was unscientific because they hadn't been bothered to be studied. And so licensure board standards, insurance standards, they started requiring all of this to be used. And so the modalities that didn't fit the template did not get studied, not because they didn't work, but because they couldn't be manualized. Internal family systems, you know, works by tracking what emerges in the room between the therapist and the patient, responding in real time. A lot of somatic therapies worked that same way. You know, it's a material that the therapist could not have predicted before the session. This leaves out the fact that you can't write a manual for things that come up in the middle of treatment. And, you know, the EVP people will say, well, then you would just go back and do a treatment plan every single time that a patient brings up a new issue or a new understanding emerges.
任何其他人都是不科学的，因为他们没有费心去进行研究。于是，执照委员会标准、保险标准开始要求使用所有这些方法。因此，那些不符合模板的模式没有得到研究，不是因为它们无效，而是因为它们无法被手册化。内在家庭系统疗法（IFS），你知道，是通过追踪治疗师和患者之间在房间里涌现的内容，并实时做出反应来发挥作用的。许多躯体疗法也是这样运作的。你知道，这是治疗师在会谈前无法预测的材料。这忽略了一个事实：你无法为治疗过程中突然出现的事情编写手册。而且，你知道，循证实践（EVP）的支持者会说，那么你每次在患者提出新问题或出现新理解时，回去重新制定治疗计划就行了。
But in really complex therapy, that's happening minute by minute, not even session by session. And that's one of the things that people not experienced in these other depth modalities and somatic modalities and experimental modalities or people who write them off and don't read them don't understand. don't understand. You know, semantic therapy, which Peter Levin makes, you know, it works by following the patient's nervous system through these cycles of activation and discharge that are felt very strongly. If you've ever done it as a patient or a provider, but you can't really measure because then you'd be stopping the person and have them answer 50 questions. Now you've changed what they're feeling. It's like quantum physics. When you observe a particle, that particle changes. And now you can't go back and study it as an unobserved particle
但在真正复杂的治疗中，这种情况是每分钟都在发生的，甚至不是按会谈来计算的。这是那些在其他深度疗法、躯体疗法和实验性疗法方面没有经验的人，或者那些否定它们、不去阅读它们的人所不理解的。你知道，彼得·莱文（Peter Levine）创造的躯体体验疗法（Somatic Experiencing），它是通过跟随患者的神经系统经历这些被强烈感受到的激活和释放周期来运作的。如果你作为患者或提供者做过这种疗法，你就知道，你无法真正衡量它，因为那样你就得停下来让对方回答50个问题。现在你已经改变了他们的感受。这就像量子物理学。当你观察一个粒子时，那个粒子就改变了。现在你无法回去把它当作一个未被观察的粒子来研究，
because you've already observed it. And so you can't put any of that into a protocol, let alone a research study. You know, these new approaches, a lot of them, they have substantial clinical evidence, you know, things like brain spotting and somatic experiencing. And the therapist trained in them report these dramatic results. You know, often with patients who failed every other type
因为你已经观察过它了。所以你无法把这些放进一个方案里，更不用说研究了。你知道，这些新方法，很多都有实质性的临床证据，比如脑点疗法（Brainspotting）和躯体体验疗法。受过这些培训的治疗师报告了显著的效果。你知道，通常是针对那些长期尝试过所有其他类型
of manualized treatment for a long time because those are more common. And then, you know, there is published research on a lot of these things, but it's usually people will say, well, it's lower quality. Yeah, it didn't cost $2 million because they, didn't have it. But the research apparatus has not funded these large-scale randomized controlled trials that would be established as this system of evidence-based practice that you had to have to be doing anything that anyone else should take seriously within that system. And the reason that it hasn't funded any of that is structural. There's no pharmaceutical company that sponsors research on
手册化治疗都失败的患者，因为那些疗法更常见。然后，你知道，关于这些疗法中有很多是有已发表的研究的，但通常人们会说，嗯，质量较低。是的，它没花200万美元，因为他们没有这笔钱。但研究机制并没有资助这些大规模的随机对照试验，而这些试验本可以建立起一套循证实践体系，让你在那个体系内被认真对待。它没有资助这些研究的原因是结构性的。没有制药公司会资助关于
therapeutic relationship because you can't patent it. And there is no device company sponsoring research on tracking the somatic field. The funding streams that built CVT's evidence bases do not exist for these modalities because they don't lead to a billable product. And they're not able to study, you know, new depression drug combined with CVT over six to 30 sessions results in this. You can't do that for somatic experiencing because those sessions can look so different because they're following the patient, not following a manual.
治疗关系的研究，因为你无法为它申请专利。也没有设备公司会资助关于追踪躯体领域的研究。建立CBT证据库的资金流并不存在于这些模式中，因为它们无法转化为可计费的产品。而且它们无法研究，你知道，比如“新抑郁症药物结合CBT进行6到30次会谈的结果”。你无法对躯体体验疗法这样做，因为那些会谈看起来差异巨大，因为它们是在跟随患者，而不是跟随手册。
And so the research just doesn't happen. And the modalities remain officially unproven, even though a lot of times. they bypass you know the academic stuff and they follow they get onto Instagram because somebody like Bessel van der Kolk or Gabor Matte wrote a book we're still here none of this changed and and so that academic incentive structure compounds a lot of these problems because you have these three forces all working in a way that never really went away but that no one remembers and that nobody really sees anymore it's just the way it is and so this is how
所以研究根本不会发生。这些模式在官方层面依然是“未经证实的”，尽管很多时候它们绕过了学术界，通过Instagram传播开来，因为像贝塞尔·范德考克（Bessel van der Kolk）或加博·马特（Gabor Mate）这样的人写了书。我们依然在这里，这一切都没有改变。这种学术激励结构加剧了许多问题，因为你有这三种力量在共同作用，它们从未真正消失，但没人记得，也没人再真正看见了，这就是现状。所以这就是
you end up with thousands of papers on CBT for depression that all cite each other. And none of them substantially advance our understanding of depression and zero papers on the semantic dimension of trauma, you know, that the field has known about clinically since, you know, Pierre Genet, basically, was writing about it in 1880, you know, but that evidence space is just not a map of clinical reality anymore. It's a map for what is funded. But we don't see that.
为什么你会看到成千上万篇关于CBT治疗抑郁症的论文，它们互相引用。但没有一篇实质性地推进了我们对抑郁症的理解。而关于创伤的躯体维度的论文却为零，你知道，该领域自1880年皮埃尔·珍妮（Pierre Janet）撰写相关内容以来，在临床上就已经知道了。但那个证据库不再是临床现实的地图，它是资助的地图。但我们看不见这一点。
And we mistake it for science. So there was a time when the academy could have served a different function, when it could have been placed where, you know, physicists or anthropology or psychoanalysts and contemplatives could collide and create these new things like the Eastland Institute in the 60s. For all of its excesses, you know, it did this, for all the weirdness of the New Age movement. They did this.
我们把它误认为是科学。曾经有一段时间，学术界本可以发挥不同的功能，本可以成为物理学家、人类学家、精神分析学家和冥想者碰撞并创造新事物的地方，比如60年代的伊斯兰研究所（Esalen Institute）。尽管它有种种过激之处，你知道，它确实做到了这一点，尽管新时代运动有种种怪异之处。他们做到了。
The Macy conferences on cybernetics did this. You know, Gregory Bateson held meetings on dolphins and schizophrenia and double-blind theory in the same room. There was cross-pollination across fields, which is how you get new ideas, is from the other sciences that are studying human. That's how you get them in psychology. You need those humanities in a way that CBT does not accommodate. And this new apparatus does not accommodate.
梅西会议（Macy conferences）关于控制论的研究做到了这一点。你知道，格雷戈里·贝特森（Gregory Bateson）在同一个房间里主持关于海豚、精神分裂症和双盲理论的会议。不同领域之间存在交叉授粉，这就是你获得新想法的方式，来自其他研究人类的科学。这就是你在心理学中获得新想法的方式。你需要那些人文科学，而CBT并不适应这一点。这套新机制也不适应。
And these institutions were containers for what we might call, you know, horizontal collision, the productive friction between disciplines that generate genuinely new ideas. And those things are gone now. And academia has siloed itself into, you know, these tiny little fields where you can't talk about something outside of your field. shouldn't even really know about it. And we're definitely not going to reward you. If anything, you're a problem. And when you do that, you get what happens after 1980, which is not really that many new modalities, not really that much more discovery, but a whole lot of papers. And, you know,
这些机构曾是我们可以称之为“水平碰撞”的容器，即学科之间产生真正新想法的生产性摩擦。现在这些东西消失了。学术界将自己孤立在这些微小的领域里，你不能谈论你领域之外的东西，甚至不应该知道它。我们绝对不会奖励你。如果有什么的话，你反而成了个麻烦。当你这样做时，你就会得到1980年之后发生的情况，即并没有多少新模式，没有多少新发现，但却有大量的论文。而且，你知道，
the bridge disciplines that would let you see patterns across all these fields like mythology and philosophy and the history of consciousness, science, other sciences, like cybernetics, like systems learning. You know, they're marginalized into electives that no graduate program required. And the interpretive capacity that would have let an American psychologist recognize the convergence between, you know, a Buddhist insight and a contemporary trauma research, or between Jungian act of imagination and internal family systems, and say, hey, these things are really saying the same thing. They're just doing it a different language. So maybe there's something neurological there that we should look under the hood and see if there's a biomarker for that, not just what we're calling diseases now.
那些能让你看到所有领域模式的桥梁学科，比如神话学、哲学、意识史、科学、其他科学，比如控制论、系统学习。你知道，它们被边缘化为研究生项目不要求的选修课。而那种本可以让美国心理学家识别出佛教洞见与当代创伤研究之间，或者荣格的“积极想象”与“内在家庭系统疗法”之间的趋同，并说“嘿，这些东西其实在说同一件事，只是用了不同的语言”的解释能力，也消失了。所以也许那里有一些神经学层面的东西，我们应该深入探究，看看是否有生物标志物，而不是仅仅关注我们现在所说的疾病。
All that's been structurally eliminated from the training pipeline, let alone the research and academic pipeline. And so the wall that the wound speaks into is not just a financial wall, but it's a diagnostic one. It's a cognitive wall built into the very structure of how knowledge is produced. And the clinicians who can actually heal are not the ones who get research funded. The researchers who get research funded are not the ones whose interventions actually work on the deepest level. levels, and definitely not in new ways. And the graduate programs that train students in the funding of research, you know,
所有这些在培训流程中都被结构性地剔除了，更不用说研究和学术流程了。所以，创伤所诉说的墙壁不仅是一堵金融墙，更是一堵诊断墙。这是一堵植入知识生产结构本身的认知墙。能够真正治愈的临床医生并不是那些获得研究资助的人。获得研究资助的研究人员并不是那些干预措施在最深层面上真正有效的人，更不用说以新的方式有效了。而那些在研究资助方面培训学生的研究生项目，你知道，
those licensure boards that credential them based on training programs, the insurance panels that reimburse them based on licensure, and the patients who arrive seeking help to get the only treatment that the system has built itself to deliver are now stuck with what we have. And, you know, Robert Spitzer aged out of running the DSM after the third edition. The fourth edition, you know, was chaired by a different psychiatrist named Francis. And Francis is the second tragic figure in the story because Francis was a careful and deliberate guy. And he had watched what the DSM3 had done and he didn't really like it. He had different problems with it than I did.
那些基于培训项目授予他们资格的执照委员会，那些基于执照进行报销的保险小组，以及那些为了获得系统所能提供的唯一治疗而寻求帮助的患者，现在都被困在了我们现有的东西里。而且，你知道，罗伯特·斯皮策（Robert Spitzer）在第三版之后就不再负责DSM了。第四版，你知道，由另一位名叫弗朗西斯（Francis）的精神科医生主持。弗朗西斯是这个故事中的第二个悲剧人物，因为弗朗西斯是一个谨慎而深思熟虑的人。他目睹了DSM-3所做的一切，他并不喜欢它。他与它有不同的问题，不像我。
But, you know, he had seen the criteria getting applied to populations that they were never designed for. He had seen ADHD explode and autism diagnosis explode to where this diagnosis of autism could mean you know, somebody who is like, sheltered a little bit too much by mom or all the way to somebody who's completely nonverbal. And it was like, this isn't science. What are we doing? You know, childhood bipolar disorder.
但是，你知道，他看到这些标准被应用到从未为之设计的群体中。他看到多动症（ADHD）爆发，自闭症诊断爆发，以至于自闭症这个诊断可以意味着，你知道，一个被妈妈保护得有点过头的人，一直到完全无法说话的人。这就像是，“这不是科学。我们在做什么？”你知道，儿童双相情感障碍。
You know, it appeared out of nowhere. And he's like, well, something like autotism should be lots of different diagnoses or something like trauma should be lots of different diagnoses. And then these other ones that are teeny tiny, like why are they even there at all? This looks like something that was invented for insurance or invented for, you know, somebody to have
你知道，它凭空出现了。他说，嗯，像自闭症这样的东西应该有很多不同的诊断，或者像创伤这样的东西应该有很多不同的诊断。然后这些其他的，微小的东西，为什么它们甚至存在？这看起来像是为了保险而发明的，或者为了，你知道，某人拥有
the kind of medical identity, essentially, were his critiques. And so Francis's entire mission with the DSM4 was, you know, to go in and to stop the medicalization of everyday life so that people could just kind of be people again. And he would tell you, he failed. The DSM4 came out in 1994 and within a decade it has presided over the three largest psychiatric epidemics in American history. ADHD and children quadrupled, children, which he was intentionally trying to stop, children, you know, childhood by bipolar disorder, which had barely existed as a diagnosis before the ESM4, became this routine label that was applied to disruptive children, you know, with corresponding prescriptions of mood
某种医学身份而发明的，这基本上是他的批评。所以弗朗西斯在DSM-4中的全部使命是，你知道，去阻止日常生活医学化，这样人们就能再次成为普通人。他会告诉你，他失败了。DSM-4于1994年出版，十年内，它见证了美国历史上三次最大的精神病学流行病。儿童ADHD增加了四倍，他本想阻止的儿童，你知道，儿童双相情感障碍，在DSM-4之前几乎不存在，却成了应用于破坏性儿童的常规标签，你知道，并伴随着对年仅四岁的孩子开具情绪
stabilizers and antipsychotics for kids as young as four. And it is real. There are some kids who need treatment. But essentially, when you move to a checkbox system, you can just have a parent kind of complain about how a child's acting, and that becomes a pathologization of the child, which is still a problem that we have. That doesn't mean that childhood mental illness isn't real. it just means that our tools for measuring it are not great and may vary based on the psychiatrists that you see just like before the DSM3 you know the autism spectrum was widened you know partly for legitimate reasons of trying to recognize mild presentations and you know um but there was still the diagnostic creep that francis abhorred and francis spent the rest of his
稳定剂和抗精神病药物。这是真实的。有些孩子确实需要治疗。但本质上，当你转向复选框系统时，你可以让家长抱怨孩子表现如何，这就成了对孩子的病理化，这仍然是我们面临的问题。这并不意味着儿童精神疾病不是真实的，这只是意味着我们衡量它的工具并不好，而且可能根据你见到的精神科医生而有所不同，就像DSM-3之前一样。你知道，自闭症谱系被扩大了，你知道，部分原因是出于试图识别轻微表现的合法原因，你知道，嗯，但仍然存在弗朗西斯所厌恶的“诊断蔓延”。弗朗西斯用他余下的
career trying to undo what he had done he wrote a book called saving normal which was you know this sort of devastating confessional, you know, written by the insider who had done it. And he gave interviews. He wrote op-eds. He said, this is wrong, and I'm the one who did it. So I should know. And it didn't matter. It changed nothing.
职业生涯试图撤销他所做的事情。他写了一本名为《拯救正常》（Saving Normal）的书，你知道，这是一种毁灭性的忏悔，你知道，由那个曾经参与其中的内部人士所写。他接受采访，写专栏文章。他说：“这是错的，而我就是那个做这件事的人。所以我应该知道。”但这没用。它什么也没改变。
The diagnostic infrastructure was already in place. The pharmaceutical companies were already marketing to these new things. They were not going to go away. And the school systems were already requiring this diagnosis to get the care that they were legally required to provide. And so the insurance and families were desperate to get those diagnoses to, to get things that they were entitled to from the schools. So the insurance companies were already reimbursing it,
诊断基础设施已经到位。制药公司已经在针对这些新事物进行营销。它们不会消失。学校系统已经要求这些诊断来提供法律规定的护理。所以保险公司和家庭都迫切需要这些诊断来获得他们有权从学校获得的东西。所以保险公司已经在报销它了，
and Francis's confession was heartfelt, it didn't matter. And the hinge of this whole story is, you know, to understand why the DSM-5 process goes the way that it does after the three and four, you know, why the resulting book is so weird and hollow. You have to understand the bet that the field had been making since the 80s. It was this bet that they keep saying, yeah, but just go ahead and get something out
弗朗西斯的忏悔是真诚的，但这没用。整个故事的关键在于，你知道，要理解为什么DSM-5的过程在3和4之后会变成那样，你知道，为什么最终的书如此怪异和空洞。你必须理解该领域自80年代以来一直在打的赌。他们一直在说：“是的，但还是先发布点什么吧，
because eventually this problem will go away and we won't have to solve it. And had it paid off, it would have retroactively justified everything that Spitzer's typewriter parties and Francis's failed attempts at, you know, restraining the industry and they would have worked.
因为最终这个问题会消失，我们不必解决它。”如果这个赌赢了，它会追溯性地证明斯皮策的“打字机派对”和弗朗西斯试图限制行业的失败尝试是合理的，它们本会奏效的。
It just, unfortunately, 30 years of pharmaceutical research dollars didn't provide the thing that they thought was going to happen. And the bet was on this thing called the brain mind problem. Bessel van der Kolk talks about this a lot and the body keeps the score. But, you know, in the DSM3, it's shipped in 1980 as this provisional document. And Spitzer and the people around him knew that the diagnostic categories were not biologically validated. And they knew that the checklist were crude and they knew that the reliability had been achieved by abandoning validity.
不幸的是，30年的制药研究资金并没有提供他们认为会发生的事情。这个赌注押在了一个叫“脑心问题”（brain-mind problem）的东西上。贝塞尔·范德考克在《身体从未忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score）中谈了很多这一点。但是，你知道，在DSM-3中，它作为一份临时文件于1980年发布。斯皮策和周围的人知道这些诊断类别没有经过生物学验证。他们知道清单很粗糙，他们知道可靠性是以牺牲有效性为代价实现的。
And they also just believed in a way that now seems kind of touchingly optimistic that the biology was coming and that once you got a, you know, diagnosis like in the DSM3, eventually, you know, people were going to figure out how to do something smart in the room, even though they weren't required to anymore. They would sit with subtlety, and they would look at the things between the numbers, which increasingly was not a thing that happened. You know, the human genome is being sequenced at this time. You've got digital imaging. You've got computers that are able to sequence something as complicated as DNA.
他们也只是以一种现在看来相当感人的乐观态度相信，生物学即将到来，一旦你有了，你知道，像DSM-3那样的诊断，最终，你知道，人们会想出如何在房间里做些聪明的事情，尽管他们不再被要求这样做了。他们会坐下来细心观察，他们会观察数字之间的东西，而这越来越不是发生的事情。你知道，人类基因组在当时正在被测序。你有数字成像。你有能够对像DNA这样复杂的东西进行测序的计算机。
It takes a lot of time, but they could do it. And so brain imaging is improving, and neurotransmitter pharmacology was generating what looked like this insight into a mechanism of action, one that didn't really materialize, or at least it's controversial. But, you know, the assumption across the field that was explicit in Spitzer's own later writings was that the DSM categories were placeholders. They were just temporary scaffolding, and it would be dismantled and replaced as this underlying biology was mapped. So just use it until the bridge gets you to the next thing. But the bridge went off a cliff. And you'd eventually just, you know, replace these major depressive disorders.
这需要很多时间，但他们能做到。所以脑成像正在改善，神经递质药理学正在产生看起来像是对作用机制的洞察，这种洞察并没有真正实现，或者至少是有争议的。但是，你知道，整个领域中在斯皮策后来的著作中明确的假设是，DSM类别是占位符。它们只是临时的脚手架，随着底层生物学的映射，它们会被拆除和替换。所以只要在桥梁带你到达下一个东西之前使用它就行了。但桥梁断了。你最终只会，你知道，用一套特定的神经生物学综合征来替换这些重度抑郁症，
with, you know, this set of specific neurobiological syndromes, and each would have its own mechanism and its own biomarker and its own medication and its own targeted treatment. And we would just know enough that if we take this book on faith, the next one we won't have to. But the 90s in the 90s is this decade of the brain where, you know, George H.W. Bush signs this proclamation and funding pours into it around neuroimaging and the Human Genome Project.
每一个都有自己的机制、自己的生物标志物、自己的药物和自己的靶向治疗。我们只需要知道足够多，如果我们对这本书深信不疑，下一本我们就不必这样了。但在90年代，这是“大脑十年”，你知道，乔治·H·W·布什签署了这份公告，资金围绕神经影像学和人类基因组计划涌入其中。
And pharmaceutical research budgets balloon. And the human genome project completes. This thing we were waiting for it to complete. And every year brought a new paper claiming to identify a brain region or a gene or a receptor subtype associated with some kind of psychiatric condition. But then all of a sudden these things don't have validity either. Nobody can agree on the numbers. And so the field is writing what felt like this exponential curve. Everyone assumed that the curve would continue when the DSM-5 task force,
制药研究预算膨胀。人类基因组计划完成。我们一直在等待它完成。每年都有新的论文声称识别出与某种精神疾病相关的大脑区域、基因或受体亚型。但突然之间，这些东西也没有有效性。没人能就数字达成一致。所以该领域正在书写一条感觉像是指数曲线的东西。每个人都假设曲线会继续。当DSM-5工作组
assembled in the late 90s on the early 2000s, was working under this explicit expectation that by the time they shipped their manual, the biology would be far enough along to fundamentally restructure psychiatric diagnosis. And they'd be able to replace it with some of these DSM-4 categories. You could replace them with biologically grounded dimensions
在90年代末到2000年代初组建时，他们是在这种明确的期望下工作的：到他们发布手册时，生物学将足够先进，可以从根本上重组精神病学诊断。他们将能够用一些DSM-4类别来替换它们。你可以用生物学基础的维度来替换它们，
and find out what the understructure was really there. The biology didn't arrive. The problem is the biology would never arrive because they were trying to find things that essentially programmed humans, that humans are just a result of their genes or a result of, you know, just something easy, not something fuzzy, not something hard,
并找出底层的结构到底是什么。生物学没有到来。问题是生物学永远不会到来，因为他们试图寻找的东西本质上是编程人类的，即人类只是他们基因的结果，或者只是，你知道，某种简单的东西的结果，而不是模糊的，不是困难的，
not something subjective. And the science never found that thing. And so, you know, the thing that's important is that, you know, after we mapped the human genome and we developed functional magnetic resonance imaging and diffusion tensor imaging and, you know, magneto, insulin, cephalography, and we spent billions of dollars on genome-wide association studies.
不是主观的东西。科学从未发现那个东西。所以，你知道，重要的是，你知道，在我们绘制了人类基因组并开发了功能性磁共振成像、弥散张量成像和，你知道，脑磁图之后，我们花费了数十亿美元进行全基因组关联研究。
We did meta-analysis after meta-analysis of these neuroimaging studies, and at the end of 30 years, the most sophisticated biological psychiatry research ever conducted, and we had not identified a single biomarker that anyone could agree on. You know, some people would tell you they found one. Your LinkedIn will definitely tell you that. But none of them could reliably diagnose a single DSM condition and a single individual patient. And not depression, not schizophrenia, not bipolar disorder, not ADHD, not autism, not anxiety. Every major category when you look at it biologically dissolves because all of these things
我们对这些神经影像研究进行了荟萃分析，30年后，这是有史以来最复杂的生物精神病学研究，我们没有确定任何一个人都能同意的生物标志物。你知道，有些人会告诉你他们找到了一个。你的LinkedIn肯定会告诉你。但没有一个能可靠地诊断单个患者的单个DSM疾病。不是抑郁症，不是精神分裂症，不是双相情感障碍，不是ADHD，不是自闭症，不是焦虑症。当你从生物学角度看时，每一个主要类别都会瓦解，因为所有这些东西
are about like William James had said, the space between the context. It's about the context of how they're connected. It's about the space between the numbers. And the brain imaging findings are, you know, this group level statistical differences that are two. That are two. small and too overlapping to diagnose in individuals. We can talk about what's going on in a group of 500 brains, probably. That's not really useful for looking at one and telling you if you have that thing. The neurotransmitter theories turned out to be these vast oversimplifications that became, the pharmaceutical industry continued to promote long after the underlying science had abandoned them.
都是关于威廉·詹姆斯（William James）所说的，上下文之间的空间。它是关于它们如何连接的上下文。它是关于数字之间的空间。而脑成像发现是，你知道，这种群体层面的统计差异，太小了，重叠太多，无法诊断个人。我们可以谈论500个大脑群体中发生了什么，可能吧。这对观察一个大脑并告诉你是否患有那种疾病并没有什么用。神经递质理论被证明是这些巨大的过度简化，制药行业在底层科学抛弃它们很久之后仍然在推广它们。
What's his name? The Maddamerica guy talks about that all the time. You know, that they said dopamine disorders. I still say dopamine disorders. Now, after studying these things for a long time, yeah, you know, dopamine, serotonin, you know, sometimes these things change as levels when you medicate somebody, but we don't really think that's the medication, the mechanism of action anymore. After spending, you know, millions and millions of dollars, we actually know less about why they
那个人叫什么名字？那个《疯狂美国》（Mad in America）的家伙一直在谈论这个。你知道，他们说多巴胺紊乱。我现在还在说多巴胺紊乱。现在，在研究了这些东西很长时间后，是的，你知道，多巴胺、血清素，你知道，有时当你给某人服药时，这些水平会改变，但我们不再认为这就是药物的作用机制了。在花费了，你知道，数百万美元之后，我们实际上对它们为什么
work. We just know our guesses are wrong on how they actually work. And, you know, there's a lot of theories. There's a lot of papers out there. There's a lot of really good theories. There is not a consensus. And for everyone who says that there is a consensus, I can find you four people that'll tell you you're wrong.
有效了解得更少了。我们只是知道我们关于它们如何实际工作的猜测是错误的。而且，你知道，有很多理论。有很多论文。有很多非常好的理论。但没有共识。对于每一个说有共识的人，我都能给你找到四个告诉你你错了的人。
I don't have a dog in the race, but there's not a consensus. We'd abandoned any kind of idea of a subjective ghost in the machine, and then we had failed to figure out how that machine worked, leaving us with what? I was born in a room of wise, buzzing light through a borrowed name. Grandma's hymn and a cracked, cassette, shaking hands while the decade changed, dusty frame on a plastic show, a soft eyes in a screen door glow, now a voice rides a broken signal through the teeth of the radio
我在这场竞争中没有利益相关，但确实没有共识。我们放弃了机器中存在主观灵魂的任何想法，然后我们又没能弄清楚那台机器是如何工作的，留给我们的是什么？我出生在一个充满智慧、嗡嗡作响的光线的房间里，借用了一个名字。奶奶的赞美诗和一张破旧的磁带，当十年过去时，颤抖的手，塑料架上布满灰尘的相框，纱门光影中柔和的眼睛，现在一个声音骑着破碎的信号穿过收音机的牙齿，
snow. Cold choirs of the machine. Sing my family. But wait, we still have to publish these books because our revenue comes. from it and they define the industry and they have to be updated because you update science. So what does that leave the DSM-5? It leaves it in a hell of weird place. The DSM-5 is hard to talk about because it was a whole lot of committees.
雪花。机器的冷合唱。歌唱我的家人。但等等，我们仍然必须出版这些书，因为我们的收入来自它，它们定义了行业，而且它们必须更新，因为你要更新科学。那么这给DSM-5留下了什么？它把它留在一个极其怪异的地方。DSM-5很难谈论，因为它是由一大堆委员会组成的。
There was no head, you know, fighting in a room after they signed NDAs and the record is sealed away. We can only kind of guess what happened based on people's politics, you know, politics of the academic psychology, not politics of politics. But, and then also like things that leak. which is pretty speculative. And so we don't have a Spitzer, we don't have a Francis that we can analyze,
没有负责人，你知道，在他们签署保密协议后在房间里争吵，记录被封存了。我们只能根据人们的政治倾向，你知道，学术心理学的政治，而不是政治的政治，来猜测发生了什么。还有，比如泄露的东西，这相当具有推测性。所以我们没有斯皮策，我们没有弗朗西斯，我们可以分析
you know, what they were doing and why. There were these factions with the DSM-5 who wanted to make the manual fully dimensional, treating conditions as these continuous spectra rather than these discrete categories because they saw that as being more scientific and more accurate, more valid. And there were factions that wanted to preserve
他们正在做什么以及为什么。DSM-5中存在一些派系，他们想让手册完全维度化，将疾病视为这些连续的谱系，而不是离散的类别，因为他们认为这更科学、更准确、更有效。还有一些派系想保留
the DSM-4 categorical structure because clinical practice had already organized around it, and they were afraid that it would be too disruptive. So there were factions who wanted to add new categories and factions who wanted to remove them. And the committees fought for a decade, and then they had to meet for a couple months. And because the biology that they were waiting for never arrived,
DSM-4的分类结构，因为临床实践已经围绕它组织起来了，他们担心这会太具破坏性。所以有派系想增加新类别，有派系想删除它们。委员会争斗了十年，然后他们不得不开会几个月。因为他们等待的生物学从未到来，
there was no external arbiter of who was right, which they had always kind of assumed that the science would be the referee, and the science never showed up. And so with the DSM-5, which is published in 2013, you know, there's this kind of negotiated monument to the fights instead of waiting for the arbiter of the brain-mind problem to be solved by the scientists.
没有谁是对的外部仲裁者，他们一直认为科学会是裁判，但科学从未出现。所以对于2013年出版的DSM-5，你知道，这是一种对争斗的协商纪念碑，而不是等待科学家解决脑心问题的仲裁者。
And so they make changes, like Asperger's is folded into autism spectrum disorder, which some researchers liked, and then it infuriated some, you know, patients and clinicians who treated that diagnosis that no longer went away or their kid was diagnosed with it, and now he has to get a different one, which means under the new paradigm, a different type. of treatment because it's a different diagnosis and these things have to be
所以他们做了改变，比如阿斯伯格综合征被并入自闭症谱系障碍，一些研究人员喜欢这样，然后它激怒了一些，你知道，治疗该诊断的患者和临床医生，那个诊断不再存在了，或者他们的孩子被诊断为那个，现在他必须得到一个不同的诊断，这意味着在新的范式下，一种不同类型的治疗，因为它是一个不同的诊断，而这些东西必须
you know prescribed based on the diagnoses under the system that we just talked about so you know there's some things about bereavement I've talked a little bit about that before and it really isn't the point of this I mean the DSM 5 is just such a weird document it's like a new nothing it's this fight-ridden compromise that preserved the infrastructure of the four while pretending to update it but without changing anything but still needing to make changes because it needed to do performative science and science is updated. And all these experts came together.
你知道，根据我们刚才谈到的系统下的诊断来开具处方。所以，你知道，关于丧亲之痛有一些事情，我之前谈过一点，这真的不是重点。我的意思是，DSM-5只是一份如此怪异的文件，它就像一个新的“虚无”。这是一个充满争斗的妥协，它保留了4的基础设施，同时假装更新它，但没有改变任何东西，但仍然需要做出改变，因为它需要进行表演性的科学，而科学是需要更新的。所有这些专家聚在一起。
So surely they contributed something, right? So, you know, the biology, the committees had bet on for 20 years, never arrived, and they still had to ship something. And so in the weeks before the publication of this thing, not even before it was out, Thomas Encel, who probably has a better line on what's going on than I do, gives this speech, you know, where he says, we're ending this enterprise. He's the director of the National Institute of Mental Health at that time. And he was by any institutional measure of the most powerful figure in American mental health research.
所以他们肯定贡献了什么，对吧？所以，你知道，委员会赌了20年的生物学从未到来，他们仍然必须发布点什么。所以在这东西出版前的几周，甚至在它出来之前，托马斯·因塞尔（Thomas Insel），他可能比我更了解正在发生什么，发表了演讲，你知道，他说：“我们正在结束这项事业。”他当时是美国国家心理健康研究所的所长。从任何机构衡量标准来看，他都是美国精神健康研究中最有权势的人物。
And he had spent his entire tenure at the DIMH, 13 years, redirecting the agency towards the neurobiological research that was supposed to validate the DSM. And then in April 2013, three weeks before the DSM-5 was scheduled to ship, Insull posts a statement. And he puts it on the NIMH blog. called transforming diagnosis. And he says in so many words, the DSM categories were not scientifically valid, not now, not ever, and they're not moving in a way
他在美国国家心理健康研究所（NIMH）任职的整整13年里，一直致力于将该机构的研究方向转向旨在验证《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）的神经生物学研究。随后在2013年4月，即DSM-5预定发布的三周前，因塞尔（Insel）发布了一份声明。他将其发布在NIMH的博客上，题为《变革诊断》。他用相当明确的措辞表示，DSM的分类在科学上并不成立，过去如此，现在如此，未来亦如此，而且它们的发展方向
towards any sort of scientific consensus or validity. And they don't correspond with any identifiable biological substrate. And as a framework for research, they're actively misleading. They're doing more harm by existing than they would if they didn't exist. And the NIH would be moving its research, funding away from the DSM categories,
并不符合任何科学共识或有效性。它们与任何可识别的生物学基础都不对应。作为研究框架，它们实际上具有误导性。它们的存在所造成的危害远大于其不存在的情况。美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）将把研究资金从DSM分类中撤出，
and towards a new framework, called the research domain criteria, Ardoc, which is something it wasn't finished. Ardoc was about 10 years from completion when he moved everything over to it. It's still not done. So this was a huge jumping of the ship, and I'm not saying that I agree with Ensel. I'm saying that that is a huge deal that most therapists and even many academics in this field don't know about. You know, the director of a federal agency had funded, you know, three decades of biological
并转向一个名为“研究领域标准”（RDoC）的新框架。这并不是一个已经完成的项目。当他将所有资源转移到RDoC时，该项目距离完成还有大约10年。至今它仍未完成。所以这是一次巨大的“弃船”行为。我并不是说我同意因塞尔的观点，我是说这是一件大事，大多数治疗师甚至该领域的许多学者都不知道。你知道，一个联邦机构的负责人资助了三十年的生物学
psychiatry. And that research was officially acknowledging that the biology that the field had been building towards never arrived and that the diagnostic system had been built in anticipation of that biology was not scientifically valid. And the thing that they had kicked down the road since the three was no longer anything that anyone was going to do. And so the walkback was immediate because this makes the whole industry freak out. You know, not the people who are, you know, doing the therapy a lot of the time, but the people who are making the money off the people doing the therapy are the ones that freak out. So the NIMH and the APA issued this joint statement together. It's pretty cold, you know, saying that the DSM-5 would remain the gold standard for clinical care,
精神病学。而那项研究正式承认，该领域一直致力于追求的生物学基础从未出现，且建立在这一生物学预期之上的诊断系统在科学上并不成立。他们自DSM-3以来一直拖延的问题，最终变成了无人能解决的难题。因此，撤回声明是立即发生的，因为这让整个行业感到恐慌。你知道，不是那些经常进行治疗的人，而是那些靠治疗师赚钱的人感到恐慌。所以NIMH和美国精神医学学会（APA）共同发布了这份联合声明。这相当冷漠，你知道，声明称DSM-5仍将是临床护理的黄金标准，
while the R-Doc would be used for research. And the clinical and research enterprises had now officially separated, which is a thing that science isn't supposed to do. The categories that determined what insurance would pay for and what diagnoses got entered into your medical record were officially declared invalid by the federal agency that funded research into the conditions that the categories named. And everyone agreed to keep using them anyway, though, because the alternative would just be to get rid of the infrastructure. But for some reason, people who concern troll that what other therapists are doing is not evidence-based practice will defend this system, or worse, not know about it at all. And this is the moment that the apparatus revealed,
而RDoC将用于研究。临床和研究企业现在正式分家了，这是科学本不该发生的事情。那些决定保险支付范围以及进入你医疗记录的诊断类别的分类，被资助这些条件研究的联邦机构正式宣布无效。但每个人都同意继续使用它们，因为唯一的替代方案就是废除整个基础设施。但出于某种原因，那些指责其他治疗师的做法不是循证实践的人，却会捍卫这个系统，或者更糟的是，根本不知道这件事。这就是该机构揭示其本质的时刻，
what it has become. It's not a science. A science commits to rules about evidence, and it lets the evidence apply to its own claims, even if that evidence threatens institutions or profit motives. You have to pick. And it's not a mythology. A mythology at least knows that it is a mythology, and it lets you argue inside of a story based on subjective rules. But the apparatus has become a secular religion, worse than either. Hard science, when it needs to exclude a dissenter, but a little interpretive framework when it needs to dodge a contradiction. And saying that this thing is not evidence-based for research because it's BS, yet, and I'm not saying which one I think, I'm just telling you what it's said. But when you're treating somebody in the room with their mental
它已经变成了什么。它不是一门科学。科学致力于证据规则，并让证据适用于其自身的声明，即使这些证据威胁到机构或利润动机。你必须做出选择。它也不是一种神话。神话至少知道自己是神话，它让你在基于主观规则的故事中进行辩论。但该机构已经变成了一种世俗宗教，比两者都糟糕。当需要排除异见者时，它表现得像硬科学；当需要回避矛盾时，它又变成了一个解释性框架。声称这东西在研究上不是循证的，因为它是一派胡言，然而——我并不是说我支持哪一方，我只是告诉你他们是怎么说的。但当你面对面治疗某人的心理
health care, it's completely evidence-based and find-to-guide treatment. If anyone has another take on how to fuse those things together, I don't. But what strange is in the 70s, much smaller problems had resulted in a crisis of confidence, for the lack of a better word, in an entire industry. And when you have somebody coming out and saying, we're going to keep doing something that we know is not really hooked up to anything, we're going to keep hitting buttons that we know are not plugged into the wall, it's something that we don't even know anymore. Because the machine has replaced so much thinking. And the machine and the apparatus is slowly revealing what it's become. You know, beneath the theological face of this thing, the infrastructure just keeps running.
健康问题时，它又是完全循证且有效的指导治疗。如果有人对如何将这两者融合有其他看法，我没有。但奇怪的是，在70年代，更小的问题曾导致整个行业出现信心危机（用词不当的话）。当你看到有人出来说，我们要继续做一些我们知道并没有真正联系到任何东西的事情，我们要继续按下我们知道没有插上电源的按钮，这甚至是我们不再了解的事情。因为机器已经取代了太多的思考。而这台机器和这个机构正在慢慢揭示它已经变成了什么。你知道，在这东西神学面孔的背后，基础设施只是在继续运转。
and the bet has been lost that we were hoping what happened for 30 years, but no one even remembers that we made it. The biology never came, but the cathedral had been built on the expectation that the biology would come, and the cathedral was holding up too much of the surrounding infrastructure to ever be demolished. So the billing codes needed these categories, and the residency programs needed categories, and the pharmaceutical marketing needed categories.
而我们过去30年所希望的赌注已经输了，但甚至没有人记得我们曾经下过注。生物学从未到来，但大教堂是建立在生物学将会到来的预期之上的，而这座大教堂支撑着周围太多的基础设施，以至于永远无法被拆除。所以账单代码需要这些分类，住院医师项目需要这些分类，制药营销也需要这些分类。
And so everyone agreed to keep worshipping in this church, whose foundation they knew was hollow, not because they still believed, but because the cathedral had become infrastructure. And the town that surrounded it, tearing it down, would take the town with it. The problem is, most people weren't making this choice actively. They were making it based on an incentive structure, a machine that made sure that they would never even know that these things had happened. An Encel himself, after leaving the NIMH in 2015, gave an interview to Wired Magazine, 2017. And I'm just going to read it.
于是每个人都同意继续在这座教堂里礼拜，尽管他们知道其地基是空洞的，不是因为他们还相信，而是因为大教堂已经成为了基础设施。而围绕它的城镇，拆除它会连同城镇一起毁掉。问题是，大多数人并不是主动做出这个选择的。他们是基于激励结构做出选择的，这台机器确保他们甚至永远不会知道这些事情曾经发生过。而因塞尔本人在2015年离开NIMH后，于2017年接受了《连线》杂志的采访。我只想读一下。
He said, I spent 13 years at the NIMH, really pushing on the neuroscience and genetics of mental disorders. When I look back on that, I realize that while I think I succeeded in getting a lot of really cool papers published by cool scientists at fairly large costs, I don't think that we move the needle in reducing suicide and reducing hospitalizations and improving recovery for the tens of millions of people who have mental illnesses in America. $20 billion, $13 years, cool papers, the needle didn't move. And this is the institutional confession of what the bet cost from the man who oversaw the betting. The people who built the system don't like it, and the system is stronger than any of these people. This is an infrastructure trap now. And like all infrastructures, it has its own logic and its own incentives, and its own self-preservation instincts.
他说，我在NIMH待了13年，真正推动了精神障碍的神经科学和遗传学研究。回顾过去，我意识到，虽然我认为我成功地让酷科学家们以相当大的成本发表了许多非常酷的论文，但我不认为我们在减少自杀、减少住院率以及改善美国数千万精神疾病患者的康复方面取得了进展。200亿美元，13年，酷论文，情况毫无改善。这就是该系统建立者对赌注代价的制度性忏悔。建立这个系统的人不喜欢它，而系统比这些人中的任何一个都强大。这现在是一个基础设施陷阱。像所有基础设施一样，它有自己的逻辑、自己的激励机制和自己的自我保护本能。
The infrastructure has produced exactly what infrastructures produce when they've lost their connection to their original purpose. It's produced the symptoms that infrastructure produces when they are operating contrary to their stated mission. The patients are not getting better. The depression rates are climbing. The anxiety rates are climbing. And I'm not saying that psychotherapy sitting in a room with someone is bad, that it will make you worse off. And I'm not even saying that psychotherapy is getting worse over the last 10 years. What I'm saying is that the way that we research, the way that we innovate, the way that we fund, the way that we talk about these things, has gotten markedly worse, which is not.
基础设施已经产生了基础设施在失去与最初目的的联系时所产生的结果。它产生了基础设施在违背其既定使命时所产生的症状。患者并没有好转。抑郁症发病率在上升。焦虑症发病率在上升。我并不是说坐在房间里与人进行心理治疗是不好的，它会让你变得更糟。我甚至不是说心理治疗在过去10年里变得更糟了。我想说的是，我们研究的方式、创新的方式、资助的方式、谈论这些事情的方式，已经变得明显更糟了，这对于
good for what's happening in the room. But there are a lot of great therapists doing really good work. If you are, if you are hurting from mental illness, I'm not telling you not to go to therapy. I'm saying that there are problems with the system that could be better. And then it shouldn't be as hard as it is for you to get funding, for you to get help and for the profession to be the clinical room, to be talking to the research room, to be talking to the academic room. And for those things to be working together to help you. That's all I'm saying. It's still your best bet. Please don't take this to mean that you should avoid a therapy or that mental health in America is bullshit.
房间里正在发生的事情没有好处。但有很多优秀的治疗师在做非常好的工作。如果你正在遭受精神疾病的折磨，我不是告诉你不要去接受治疗。我是说这个系统存在可以改进的问题。你不应该在获得资助、获得帮助以及让专业领域——临床室、研究室、学术室——进行对话方面遇到如此大的困难。让这些东西协同工作来帮助你。这就是我想说的。这仍然是你最好的选择。请不要认为这意味着你应该避免治疗，或者美国的心理健康是一派胡言。
That's not what I'm saying. What I'm saying is that there are very real problems with this system that we need to look at. You know, the opioid epidemic is killing Americans more than the Vietnam were killed. But we don't feel these things anymore. You know, the drugs that the apparatus prescribes are being shown in study after study to be effective, but not really is effective for most things that are not, you know, a dopamine disorder like schizophrenia, to not really be more effective than therapy. the therapy apparatus that the apparatus reimburses us on it's making things briefer shorter shallower
我不是那个意思。我想说的是，这个系统存在非常现实的问题，我们需要审视。你知道，阿片类药物流行导致美国人的死亡人数超过了越战死亡人数。但我们不再感受到这些了。你知道，该机构开出的药物在研究中被反复证明是有效的，但对于大多数不是多巴胺障碍（如精神分裂症）的疾病来说，它们并不比治疗更有效。该机构报销的治疗机构正在使治疗变得更简短、更浅显，
and then what then what patients actually need even if they don't know that they need that and the apparatus is is generating symptoms that it claims to treat you have some things that prescribe medications that have the same side effects as the condition how do you tease those apart when you're so reliant on medication without therapy. You know, a therapist might be able to tell, but a psychiatrist in 15 minutes, like, that is very hard for them to do in 15 minutes because it takes a very qualified therapist weeks some of the time.
比患者实际需要的更浅显，即使他们自己不知道需要什么。该机构正在制造它声称要治疗的症状。你有一些开具药物的处方，这些药物具有与疾病相同的副作用。当你如此依赖药物而没有治疗时，你怎么能把它们区分开来呢？你知道，治疗师也许能分辨出来，但精神科医生在15分钟内，这对于他们来说非常困难，因为这有时需要一位非常有资质的治疗师花费数周时间。
You know, the wound is still speaking that we talked about in the last episode. The conspiracy theories, the cults, you know, the changing content of madness, the paranoid style of culture is turning into a dissociative one. But the wound is still speaking. It's always speaking. And the question of this series, the question I keep returning to, is whether there is anything left in the apparatus that can hear that enough to respond to it. In the next episode, we're going to look at what happens when the apparatus' own data
你知道，我们在上一集谈到的伤口仍在说话。阴谋论、邪教，你知道，疯狂内容的改变，文化的偏执风格正在变成一种解离风格。但伤口仍在说话。它一直在说话。这个系列的疑问，我不断回归的疑问是，该机构中是否还有任何东西能听到这些并做出回应。在下一集中，我们将看看当该机构自己的数据
starts making the case against the apparatus, not just the failed bet on biology, but the flagship clinical trial of the medication first paradigm. An honest reanalysis of the largest antidepressant study ever funded by the federal government And it would show that the sustained recovery rate of the standard treatment paradigm was 2.7%. The published headline was 67%. Big difference. The replication crisis that swept psychology starting around 2011 found fewer than 40% of the foundational findings that the field had bet itself on could be reproduced. And the drugs were shown to be barely distinguishable from placebo. and nothing about the clinical apparatus changed.
开始反驳该机构时会发生什么，不仅仅是生物学赌注的失败，还有“药物优先”范式的旗舰临床试验。对联邦政府资助的最大规模抗抑郁药研究的一次诚实重新分析显示，标准治疗范式的持续康复率为2.7%。而发表的头条新闻是67%。差距巨大。从2011年左右开始席卷心理学的复制危机发现，该领域所依赖的基础发现中，只有不到40%可以被复制。而且药物被证明与安慰剂几乎没有区别。但临床机构没有任何改变。
And again, it's not just that this happened. It's that no one knows. And that is the next episode. You know, the apparatus's own data destroying the apparatus's own case. And the apparatus continuing to operate anyway. Because the infrastructure has become independent of the truth. It's become independent of science that originally justified it. And the cold machine running on its own momentum with the warm ghost locked outside,
再说一次，不仅仅是这件事发生了。而是没有人知道。这就是下一集的内容。你知道，该机构自己的数据摧毁了该机构自己的案例。而该机构却继续照常运作。因为基础设施已经独立于真理。它已经独立于最初证明其合理性的科学。冰冷的机器靠着自己的惯性运转，而温暖的幽灵被锁在外面，
banging on the wall, speaking in tongues that no one is trained to hear. The paranoid style is increasingly becoming a dissociative one, with the people whose job it is to know these things for some reason don't know, don't care, and don't talk about them. Laugh and dial-up shrieks, yeah. Tiny metal birds, wings of green tear. I'm humming. Wants a back in cold to guitar,
在墙上敲打，说着没人受过训练去听的方言。偏执的风格正日益变成一种解离的风格，而那些工作职责就是了解这些事情的人，出于某种原因，不知道、不在乎，也不谈论它们。笑声和拨号上网的尖叫声，是的。微小的金属鸟，绿色的泪水之翼。我在哼唱。想要回到冰冷的吉他声中，
slightly bending on a trembling silver road. to warm ghosts, cold machines, space between breath and sweat on on your fever dreams. You're never caught in your fever dream. Hey guys, thanks for listening. I wanted to remind you to check out the website, get therapy,
在颤抖的银色道路上微微弯曲。致温暖的幽灵，冰冷的机器，呼吸与汗水之间的空间，在你发烧的梦里。你永远不会被困在你的发烧梦中。嘿，伙计们，谢谢收听。我想提醒你们去看看网站，gettherapy,
Birmingham.com. We got a robust blog with lots of different articles that spark different times of engagement. And I really genuinely make these because I like connecting with the people who they connect with. If you want to submit an email, I am covered up with those.
Birmingham.com。我们有一个强大的博客，里面有很多不同的文章，在不同时间激发参与感。我真的非常真诚地制作这些内容，因为我喜欢与那些能产生共鸣的人建立联系。如果你想提交电子邮件，我已经收到了很多。
I do genuinely like getting them and I like conversing. Thank you for listening and look forward to part seven next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我确实非常喜欢收到它们，也喜欢交流。感谢收听，期待下周的第七部分。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。